figaro live 21h55 bonsoir bienvenue nous
sommes en direct pour cette grande
soirée d'élection les élections
législatives vous le savez vous avez vu
le score au niveau national c'est très
serré entre ensemble le groupement le
collectif la coalition de la majorité et
puis la nuit baisse de jean-luc
mélenchon et de la gauche en général
mais je ne rejoue je ne vous refais pas
ses scores ici ses résultats au niveau
national parce qu'ici on vous donne les
résultats dans votre circonscription
voulez savoir qui est au 2e tour chez
vous c'est ici que ça se passe il ya
peut-être même des députés déjà élu on
va voir tout ça bonsoir adrien brillant
bonsoir thibault comment se voient tous
ça va très bien oui parce que sans
adrien papa de pas de live adrien du
figaro.fr c'est lui ce soir votre votre
porte voix vous nous expliquer comment
on va fonctionner alors c'est très
simple
on nous sommes en direct la thibault sûr
sur youtube sur facebook sur le site
lefigaro.fr et sur twitch pas ça fait
beaucoup ça fait beaucoup et donc ça
fait 4 chat en tout donc dans le chat
vous pouvez demander donc soit les
résultats dans votre commune soient les
résultats dans votre circonscription on
espère aller voir s'il pourra même faire
les deux un peut-être parce que si vous
ne donnez par exemple savez peut-être
pas le nom de votre circonscription des
fois on s'est pas le héros un homme vous
nous donnez le nom de la commune et puis
nous on cherche la circonscription je
vois déjà des gens qui connaît sa
circonscription donc des assassins sont
certains sont très au courant mais ce
qu'on privilégiant par exemple d'accord
on regardera ça voilà donc comme
d'habitude vous connaissez le principe
on va essayer de prendre le maximum de
commentaires on ne pourra pas faire tout
le monde non voilà on vous demande juste
d'être courtois et ne doutait pas de nos
interviews je ne doute pas je nie alors
on va se mettre sur ce format là vous
voyez comme ça vous avez mon écran
adrien me donne le nom de la commune que
vous souhaitez chercher on la cherche
alors pour tout vous dire nous recevons
les résultats du ministère de
l'intérieur c'est comme ça que ça se
passe exactement voilà on reçoit les
résultats du ministère de l'intérieur
qui sont rentrés sur lefigaro.fr et des
fois ça prend un peu de temps pour avoir
la circonscription alors on va chercher
sur lefigaro.fr et vous inquiétez pas on
a une petite solution les fouilles est
directement sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur si par hasard on n'arrive
pas à voir encore notre circonscription
sur lefigaro.fr c'est quelque chose que
ce qu'on va faire que les gens peuvent
faire chez eux adrien exactement donc on
a on a un moteur de recherche sur le sur
le site je vais vous mettre le lien
d'ailleurs tout de suite à voile à
l'école
voilà vous pouvez nous le demander c'est
le jeu mais vous pouvez effectivement
allé le chercher directement et puis et
puis nous notre petit avantage c'est que
on essaie de s'amuser un peu un adrien
est très concentré avec moi j'essaie de
le troubler un peu avec des bêtises et
puis surtout on essaye de régler notre
géographie c'est vrai que des fois on
sait pas on connaît pas toutes les
communes vous allez voir on va passer un
moment ensemble vous n'hésitez pas
est-ce qu'on a une première demande on
va prendre une première demande ou sur
facebook
c'est ghislaine qui bonsoir les
résultats dans la ville de woustviller
avoue commencer tout de suite avec des
noms compliqués jijel est en difficulté
alors je fais un petit pari ça c'est
dans l'est et en alsace 50 7 915 50 7
915 alors 57
915 est-ce qu'on avoue stvi l'air
exactement nous y sommes c'est en
moselle alors on a les résultats vous
voyez dans la commune avec le
rassemblement national qui arrivait en
tête
devant ensemble et regarder alors où
elle annule ps elle est là en seulement
seulement en quatrième position dans
cette commune nous ce qui nous intéresse
c'est de connaître le résultat dans la
circonscription alors oui il ya un petit
bouton un tout petit peu plus bas il est
ici ce bouton on clique dessus et on va
voir si on a les résultats n'ont pas
encore on n'a pas encore les résultats
dans la 5e circonscription de la moselle
mais essayons de faire d'une autre
manière on a dit qu'on allait chercher
on va aller sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur comme ceux ci la moselle 57
c'est bien sa circonscription je vérifie
on est dans la cinquième c'est sa
cinquième circonscription est ce qu on a
les résultats oui alors on a deux
qualifiés au second tour vous les voyez
c'est le rassemblement national et l air
voilà qui sont au deuxième tour c'est
très serré vous voyez très serré très
serré alors rappelez nous quand même
comment on se qualifie c'est pas
toujours simple ça oui alors il faut il
faut donc pour être on peut être élu dès
le premier tour il faut faire 25 % des
voix des inscrits et pas des 12 5% des
inscrits c'est bien ça ah oui on va se
qualifier 25% pour être qualifié dès le
premier tour donc donc on parle bien d
un script le départ d d exprimer et pour
se qualifier au second tour il faut
faire 12 5% des inscrits mais alors là
vous voyez regarder dans ce cas de
figure expliqué moi alors il ya la
capture donc là effectivement il nous
faut forcément des candidats pour un
second tour donc là ce qui va se passer
c'est que ce sont 2 les deux premiers
candidats donc celui du r n est celui
des républicains qui vont se qualifier
pour le second tour même s'ils n'ont pas
atteint 12 5% des inscrits ça il faut un
deuxième tour donc si par exemple il ya
qu un seul candidat qui arrive à plus de
12 5% des inscrits il ne sera pas tout
seul le deuxième tour exactement le
second sera face à lui dans une semaine
on va avoir plusieurs cas 1 ce soir je
pense de deux candidats qui sont
qualifiés malgré tout la bon c'est vrai
que c'est c'est vrai quand on a des
résultats très serrés comme celui ci on
fait pas dans 12 5% des inscrits encore
moins et on sera attentif si vous nous
trouvez la commune où link 20 la
circonscription il ya des triangulaires
parce que par le passé il y en a eu
beaucoup mais avec si peu d'inscrits est
difficile de se qualifier donc on
cherchera s'il ya des triangulaires même
des quadrangulaires on le porte parole
et nous devons donc on avait commencé
avec ghislaine et sa commune de
vauvillers sais j'ai bien compris si je
m'en souviens bien la 5e circonscription
de la moselle vous avez vu qualifier au
second tour la droite et le
rassemblement national oui
alors on ne peut prendre un deuxième
commentaire sur facebook oui ils rendent
marie-annick bonsoir bienvenue les
résultats à mireval mireval est ce que
j'ai écrit correctement oui mais un val
dans le 34 exactement le département de
l'hérault vous voyez dans cette petite
commune à mireval rassemblement est en
tête devant la nuit baisse c'est très
serré avec ensemble allons voir si on a
les résultats dans cette circonscription
de la de l'hérault c'est la huitième et
n'ont toujours pas de résultat ici mais
allons voir sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur l'hérault est ce qu'on peut
trouver ça ensemble le 34 on y va
tranquillement les recettes ici on a dit
quelle circonscription la huitième il me
semble et 8,6 alors regard des résultats
partiels nous avons plus de 40% des
électeurs voilà sur une base de 79 % des
électeurs inscrits donc on précise que
ce ne sont pas des résultats définitifs
et donc il est très difficile pour
l'instant de vous dire qui est au second
tour parce que vous vouliez que c'est
très serré entre le candidat et rennes
qui lui est en tête il ya une petite
avance et derrière la nuque ps et
ensemble des manuels macro et dans
marche 11,73 contre 11,35 c'est très
très serré là on est à à 300 voix des
cartes donc mariannick c'est ça c'est ça
on ne peux pas encore vous donner
exactement
le la fiche du second tour la semaine
prochaine mais vous voyez que le fn
arrive en tête pour l'instant dans cette
circonscription et que c'est très serré
derrière entre la nuque ps et ensemble
et c'est moins facile on a fait ça
souvenez vous il ya un mois et demi avec
la présidentielle c'était beaucoup plus
clair 1 il va falloir prendre le temps
de tout analyser allez on continue à les
patients sur youtube maintenant vous
êtes très nombreux d'ailleurs sur
youtube sa joindre on verra non soir
tous on verra quel autre qui du
figaro.fr de youtube de twitch la plus
grosse communauté vous misez sur youtube
vous mais pour l'instant je me suis le
tue mais je ne désespère pas de facebook
y sont ils sont très nombreux également
sur youtube on apprendre le la demande
de diaba sakho qui nous demandent les
résultats à massy massy alors on
rappelle bon massy ça devrait aller mais
que les grosses communes c'est un peu
plus difficile a expliqué m
il ya forcément
plus de
bulletins dépouillés donc ça viendra
plus tard dans la soirée alors ça
viendra normalement plus rapidement que
lors de la présidentielle c'est dû
également faire notamment au taux
d'abstention
forcément moins les gens votent et oui
plus long des boulevards à terrain en
vendée où il rapidement voilà mais on
reviendra un peu plus tard dans l'est
dans les grandes villes vous faites
preuve d'une logique implacable
mathématiques les
méchants en plus de réaliser notre
géographie on va aussi réviser nos maths
alors investi on n'a même pas les
résultats oui on a vu tout à l'heure
dans l'essonne pour tout vous dire on
peut voir les résultats qui arrivent les
scènes arriver un peu plus tard on verra
mais allons voir sur le sur le site du
ministère de l'intérieur ce qu'on nous
dit est-ce qu'on a quelque chose dans
l'essonne à massy alors je vais regarder
quelle circonscription massy la 6e
circonscription de l'essonne donc
l'essonne ap pop up attention on ne se
perd pas on trouve tout doucement
essonne 91
dans la sixième circonscription allons
regarder moins de 40% des électeurs les
résultants du mal à arriver dans
l'essonne où vous a dit que c'est un peu
difficile donc si vous venez de
l'essonne et vous attendez des résultats
rené dans une heure c'était un score
alors messieurs voilà mais on y
retournera évidemment bien sûr aller re
re patients sur facebook ont à cet effet
un oui bonjour stéphanie bienvenue vue
demande
baugé en ange baugé en anjou sa jolie un
très joli on va pouvoir faire ce
concours à vous laver mais rappelle le
petit concours qui vous a plu lors de la
présidentielle nous on avait fait un
concours des noms de villes les plus les
plus jolies les plus agréables à
l'oreille alors c'était très subjectif
oui c'était dictatorial donc vous avez
raison baugé sur anjou on n'avait pas
fait que ça mais on dira les autres
concours 1 qu'on a fait tout à l'heure
alors ça s'écrit comme ça alors ça
s'écrit avec un ça s'écrit à vue a eu
beau et appelé après un j g
/ ans et je les regarde et il est ici
baugé en anjou c'est dans le maine et
loire vous voyez dans cette petite
commune ce sont les républicains qui
sont arrivés en tête avec 28% des voix
devant la nuit passée le rassemblement
national c'est assez serré vous avez vu
qu'il ya quatre il ya quatre partis qui
sont au-delà des 20% dans cette petite
commune allons voir peut-être que nous
avons les résultats dans la troisième
circonscription du maine-et-loire
toujours pas vous arrivez pas me trouver
tout ça mais regardez maine et loire on
a dit qu'on pouvait le trouver sur le
ministère de l'intérieur et on y va tout
doucement alors c'est comme ça maine et
loire 49 quelle circonscription 3e 3e
pour cette petite commune de beaugeay en
anjou je vous propose qu'on aille voir à
quoi ça ressemble un trait si vous
voulez voyager en anjou troisième
circonscription la même les résultats
définitifs et vous voyez donc qu'au
deuxième tour sont qualifiés la
candidate dlr madame anne laure blain et
elle sera face à véronique roues des
beach de la nuque baisse le
rassemblement national et est éliminé de
peu un os ça se jouera à 400 voix vous
voyez la petite différence et 6,7 1803
7411 on surveillera parce que comme il
ya peu d'électeurs on va pouvoir voir
celui qui est éliminée avec le plus
petit écart qui aura la frustration de
ne pas avoir fait un marché en plus vous
savez pas ce que c'est sourire comme ça
on va serrer des mains et puis on gagne
les électeurs comme ça dans les
élections locales voilà pour ces
résultats dans la troisième
circonscription du maine et loire allez
on a dit qu'on allait voir baugé oui
alors allons voir bouger en bauges et en
anjou on peut faire comme ça à regarder
alors baugé en anjou voyons où c'est
déjà oui on est on est près d'angers un
film il n'y a pas de secret baugé en
anjou et regardez moi cette magnifique
bâtisse commence très bien c'est pas
plus qu'une bâtisse 1 c'est le château
de baugé ça vous plaît ça ouais alors on
va noter parce que pour l'instant on a
un effet aussi souvenez-vous le plus bel
endroit de france qui nous avait été
proposé oui c'est vrai plus beau non
plus bel endroit de france pour c'était
pour nos vacances oui c'est vraiment on
démarre assez bien joué ce soir baugé en
anjou moi je pense qu'il ya de quoi
faire à baugé en anjou salaire salaire
très très beau allez on continue baugé
en anjou et je note plus joli village
pour l'instant c'est ce que nous a
proposée stephen je vais prendre le
commentaire de mafalda sur le site c'est
le premier commentaire bonjour soir
mafalda parce que voilà on rappelle à on
est en direct sur facebook sur youtube
et sur le site du figaro.fr mafalda donc
nous demande les résultats de d'un gie
sinclair à d'un gie sinclair alors
allons-y on va essayer de trouver ceux
des résultats d'un gie sinclair n'a les
résultats dans cette commune de haute
savoie véronique rio temps qui est
député un déjà qui s'étend en tête dans
cette circonscription 39% des voix ces
matchs à 2 face à anne valérie duval de
la nuque baisse et allant voir peut-être
que nous avons les résultats allez on
croise les doigts dans la première
circonscription de savoie n'ont toujours
pas sur le site du figaro.fr mais il est
possible de les trouver vous allez voir
sur le site du ministère de l'intérieur
haute savoie 74 allons voir qui est
qualifié au deuxième tour attend les
résultats dans la première
circonscription oui et donc je peux vous
annoncer que véronique verton rio ton
est en ballotage extrêmement favorable
vous avez vu 36 35 pour cent des
suffrages devant donc la candidate de la
nuque hassan valérie duval ce sera donc
un match à deux entre ensemble et la
nuque ps mais aussi l'avantagé quand
même assez nette pour véronique rio
temps et qui semble plus avoir le le
report de voir vous avez vu derrière l
air fait un très bon score avec 6830
voix s'est bien engagé pour pour la
députée sortante de la première
circonscription de haute-savoie
sur facebook nous arrivons coralie qui
insiste pour avoir les résultats de
chantilly elle a raison d'insister
coralie parce que je sais que des fois
vous fait du favoritisme
alors coralie bonjour bienvenue on y va
chantilly attend les résultats à
chantilly oui nous avons les résultats à
chantilly a emmené avec une personnalité
oui eric woerth l'a largement devant
eric woerth largement en tête devant
visiblement las nubes et le
rassemblement national
allons voir qui est qualifié au second
tour dans cette circonscription nous
avons peut-être les résultats dans
l'oise non mais vous avez bien compris
notre petite mécanique on va sur le site
du ministère de l'intérieur on cherche
l'oise évidemment aller l'ordre
alphabétique loiseleux 60 quelle
circonscription nous avons dit chante
ici la 4e 4 dans l'oise et je vous
laisse annoncé que au second tour sont
qualifiés donc eric woerth et audrey
anglaise et donc nous n'avons pas de
candidat de l'ani baisse dans ce second
tour oui de l'oise nous avons donc un
duel finalement un remake de la
présidentielle entre eric woerth qui n'a
pas beaucoup d'avancé comme vous le
voyez face à la candidate du
rassemblement national on surveillera ça
de près parce que c'est vrai qu'il eric
woerth a rejoint il ya peu la majorité
présidentielle nous verrons si c'est un
pari réussi et s'il réussit à devenir
redevenir député eric woerth dans la 4e
circonscription de l'oise allons-y on
continue parce qu'on a du monde dit -
oui on a du monde sur youtube on à
raphaël qui nous demande on jouera fin à
clamart à clamart alors ville de région
parisienne
des fois c'est difficile et oui comme
vous le voyez c'est un peu tôt pour que
la mare 12e circonscription des
hauts-de-seine allons voir peut-être
qu'on a ici on n'a pas tous les chiffres
que savait que sur le ministère
l'intérieur on peut trouver parfois des
résultats assez avancé dans les
hauts-de-seine en a 10 4e
circonscription n'ont regardé et oui
région parisienne il explique nous avons
moins de 40 % des électeurs inscrits
donc non pour l'instant il est un peu
tôt pour les hauts-de-seine allez dans
une petite heure on est là jusqu'à
minuit nous vous avez le temps de passer
vous pouvez aller sur le live de la
grande soirée des législatives
d'ailleurs je sais enchères afin que
nous sommes en ce moment sur ce live de
la grande soirée des législatives vous
avez suivi vincent roux et bruno drye
devons tout analyser tous les résultats
pour vous est bien ici nous on cherche
les résultats dans votre commune et dans
votre circonscription donc vous vous
venez ici peuvent nous rejoindre parce
que c'est vrai que là nous on n'est pas
sur ceux sur ce flux là mais on peut
expliquer aux gens oui alors en fait il
ya deux live en ce moment sur sur le
figaro donc oui on est partout on est
partout où nous nous sommes sur facebook
sur youtube sur twitter et sur
lefigaro.fr donc si vous allez sur la
sur le site du figaro vous descendez un
petit peu vous allez nous trouver sur
facebook également dans les vidéos
youtube pareil dans les vidéos et sur
twitch
la chaîne figaro live vous nous
rejoignez dans le chat vous nous donnez
le nom de votre commune ou si vous si
vous connaissez le numéro de votre
circonscription dans votre département
vous pouvez nous donner également et on
s'occupe du reste on s'occupe du reste à
les regarder on donne un exemple
alors alors là j'avais encore une
commune en jean en région parisienne
envoie peut-être évité on va attendre un
peu pour la région parisienne pour les
bureaux de vote ferment un peu plus tard
et donc les dépouillements ont lieu un
peu plus tard et donc les résultats nous
arrive un peu plus tard alors on peut
tenter sophie sur facebook qui nous
demandent soir sophie amplepuis dans le
rhône ample amplepuis alors là on
avisera déjà redit que je l'essaie alors
si je devais décrire je l'écrirai comme
ça exactement compris la vie tout de
suite collé tout de suite d'une
magnifique le site du figaro alors
nathalie serre est en tête pour les
républicains dans cette petite commune
devant la new baisse mais regardez c'est
très serré une petite voix d'écart dans
cette commune entre le rassemblement
national et et la nièce et puis même
ensemble est juste derrière alors allons
voir peut-être que sur l'ensemble de la
circonscription
on a un résultat c'est la 8ème
circonscription du rhône suspense avant
de moi résultats oui regardez au
deuxième tour eh bien nous avons deux
qualifiés dominique despras deux
ensembles et nathalie serre des
républicains malheureusement la nuque
psg est éliminé 1 19 points 25% des voix
ça suffit pas malheureusement pour
accéder au second tour
donc nous aurons donc un duel entre
ensemble et des républicains dans cette
huitième circonscription du rhône voilà
comment ça marche nous rejoignent et si
vous avez des questions vous nous posez
vous nous posez tout ça adrien vouliez
puis moi je cherche ici est-ce qu'on a
autre chose ah oui alors on à claude qui
soir claude connaît la circonscription
inscriptions directement on peut essayer
de trouver claude claude
souhaite savoir les résultats donc dans
la 4e circonscription eux
de côtes-d'armor côtes d'armor allons-y
les côtes d'armor
comme ceux ci à l'heure est-ce qu'on a
des circonscriptions la 4e regardez vous
tapez le nom du département et là vous
pouvez trouver donc la circonscription
la quatrième non nous n'avons
malheureusement pas encore les résultats
mais vous avez bien compris notre petite
astuce on va trouver ça sur le sur le
ministère de l'intérieur parce qu'on
compliqué rappelle que c'est évidemment
le ministère de l'intérieur qui fournit
voilà les chiffres
aux médias bien sûr et ce sont les
chiffres officiels évidemment côtes
d'armor 4e circonscription des résultats
sont tombés les résultats officiels et
donc vous pouvez voir que dans cette
circonscription et bien nous aurons un
duel finalement le duel nationale entre
la nuque ps madame muriel l'aide frau
est au second tour devant yannick
kerlogot kerlogot on sais pas peut-être
que claude peut nous dire si ce sont son
candidat comment comment on prononce
11280 ça se voit c'est très serré à
peine 600 voix d'écart on aura donc un
duel et vous voyez derrière le rapport
de forces est bien rn7 1027 voix il ya
un divers-gauche à 5000 donc peut-être
que la nuque ps pourra profiter madame
muriel le prêt le bureau pourra profiter
de ce report devoir vous savez tout
claude sur votre quatrième
circonscription des côtes d'armor on a
une autre circonscription à vous même
les gens présents dans sa route sa
voiture mais j'aimerais beaucoup y est
déjà allé on y retourne c'est kevin sur
youtube qui nous demandent boom mon cher
kevin alors beaumont mais où mahiedine
circonscription directement lens passe à
wade alors il précise que c'est donc la
quatrième celle qu'on s'est par ailleurs
gardé abdou labo j'évite de moi je
l'aimé bien parce que vous savez mon
attachement pour la haute-savoie donc je
le salue je sais que j'ai évidemment et
donc je lui donne les résultats à
beaumont c'est une petite commune où les
républicains sont arrivés en tête devant
ensemble et la nuque mais c'est assez
serré d'ailleurs entrés ensemble et la
nuque baisse et allons voir si on a les
résultats sur le site du figaro pour
cette 4e circonscription de haute-savoie
non pas encore mais nous avons notre
note manip habituel le site du ministère
de l'intérieur 74 la haute savoie nous
sommes ici à je suis en savoie ne pas se
tromper attention c'est pas tout à fait
pareil je reprends haute savoie alors
c'est pas forcément très simple c'est
ici j'ai trouvé
4e circonscription et nous avons donc un
second tour entre la lr virginie duby
muller face à la candidate ou au
candidat pardon valérian vers voûte de
la nuit baisse ensemble et éliminer
antoine vieillard ne sera pas au second
tour et ça joue à pas grand-chose 7990
voix contre
7678 voie est donc ici on peut rappeler
un la route inca qui voilà qui illustre
ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure pour
accéder au second tour il faut faire 12
5% des inscrits exactement sauf qu'ils
savent vous êtes sûrs d'y aller voilà
vous êtes sûrs d'y aller ici donc le
candidat de l'ani baisse
fait seulement 9% des inscrits oui donc
normalement c'est pas suffisant mais
elle et elle est deuxième oui c'est un
monsieur valéry leur excusez moi mais il
est deuxième donc dans tous les cas ils
accèdent exactement il n'y aura pas de
second tour avec un seul candidat non
vous pouvez vous qualifier avec moins de
12 5% des inscrits si vous êtes deuxième
mois là
alors j'ai très envie de retourner sur
le site du figaro.fr mais oui parce que
c'est des gens qui viennent directement
nous voir sur le site on les aime
beaucoup ouais c'est toujours mafalda
qui nous demandent les résultats de
l'argentière la bessée à l'argentière la
bessée yucel compris elle a vu qu'il y
avait beaucoup de monde sur youtube et
sur facebook de magix malines alors vous
aussi vous venez sur lefigaro.fr vous
pouvez trouver ce grand live sur lequel
nous sommes toujours le grand live de la
soirée présidentielle vous allez
retrouver dans un temps d'un instant
brune d'audrey et vincent euros et nous
on cherche les résultats vous descendez
un petit peu vous allez très vite nous
trouver et vous posez vos questions à
dre regarder à l'argentière la bessée à
joël giraud vous souvenez c'était le
ministre des territoires de la
transition dont c'était quoi déjà
c'était la cohésion des territoires et
lui semble il avait remplacé jacques une
gourou souvenez vous quand elle était
partie au conseil constitutionnel il est
député il se présente pour la cinquième
fois de suite il fait un très bon score
dans sa commune de l'argentière la
bessée 37,89 % des voix c'est serré avec
la candidate delà de la nuit passée
allons voir peut-être qu'on a les
résultats dans la dans la
circonscription 2e circonscription des
hautes-alpes oui qualifié pour le second
tour joaillerie 38 0 4% des voix et bien
partis quand même l'ancien ministre et
puis il sera face à la nuque ps 29 22 %
des voix bon score intéressant pour
l'ancien ministre mais ce n'est pas fait
il faudra encore travailler une petite
semaine pour être à nouveau député un
report des voix favorables à l'est où
est-ce qu'on peut partir maintenant je
vais me dit mon cher you tube
qu'est-ce qu'on harman qui nous
demandent les résultats la deuxième
circonscription de lyon sont ils
disponibles alors lyon en tête mais sait
on c'est difficile parce que parce que
vous savez alors il faut faire
d'ailleurs ça me semble que c'est rhône
il faut taper rhône 2e circonscription
voilà est comme ça vous avez des
résultats non on n'a malheureusement pas
les résultats en tout cas sur le sur le
site parce que sur le site il nous faut
avoir les résultats complets que tous
les bureaux de vote soit soient ouverts
allons voir peut-être sur le site du
ministère l'intérieur qui affiche les
résultats petit à petit à petit 69 le
rhône et non regard des résultats
incomplets seulement 40% des électeurs
inscrits expliquez-nous adrien ney dans
les grandes villes c'est plus difficile
c'est plus difficile bon allez on les
aura plus tard dans la soirée on
rappelle que ce moteur de recherche que
nous utilisons dieu donc sur lefigaro.fr
et accessible à tous donc vous pouvez
vous veillez à les plus tard dans la
soirée ou bien restez avec nous oui ça
c'est le principal voilà surtout que
vous êtes très sympathique exe ça je
tiens à le dire aux internautes il est
très sympathique et il est là pour vous
aidez moi je fais que taper leurs
finalement le nom de la commune que vous
recherchez allons allons-y on poursuit
on poursuit raphaël sur youtube bonsoir
offre/demande rouen alors que cette
chaire et éclat à asselah je sais
presque romantique voyez-vous cherche
les résultats à rouen c'est mieux aussi
je l'écris correctement rond grandes
villes nous aurons peut-être pas les
résultats tout de suite à rouen alors
regardé plusieurs circonscriptions et
oui mais c'est ça alors il faut demander
la circonscription à raphaël et oui
parce qu'il est toujours dans les
grandes villes il y a plusieurs il ya
plusieurs circonscriptions parfois
regardé la première est là et la
troisième mais on a par exemple les
résultats dans la première
circonscription donnons lui ces
résultats la qualifier pour le second
tour le candidat de l'ani ps maxime da
silva devant damien adam d'ensemble
assez largement devant tous les autres
33 % pour la gauche 28 20 % pour pour le
centre et regarder qui arrive en
troisième position divers gauche avec
11% des voix un report des voix qui est
peut-être favorable à maxime da silva
dans cette 1re circonscription de seine
maritime c'est rouen on a dit alors est
ce qu'on regarde là
c'était la troisième si vous voulez
quand je regarde la 3e salon si la même
les résultats dans la quête d'un prix
juste ça comme ça rappelle alors là
c'est encore plus net vous avez vu son
score 44,21 % des voix s'est pas fait
mais c'est bien parti pour hubert
wulfranc qu devant salomé tessier du
rassemblement national nous verrons pour
qu'il vote les électeurs d'ensemble
puisque laetitia au 6 bis arrive en
troisième position avec 16 41 % des voix
ça joue à pas grand chose mais c'est
bien la candidate du rassemblement
national qui sera au second tour la
semaine prochaine et donc pour l'instant
personne ne se qualifie noyer l'on peut
être complet 1 il nous demandait comme
ça un peu un peu au hasard des insultes
à rouen notre cher rafale et bien on lui
donne tous les résultats
alors où est ce qu'on peut aller mais
facebook oui mon rappel facebook ce
facebook youtube le figaro.fr et twitch
oui bien sûr alors on n'a pas eu de
fuite encore mais n'hésitez pas à vous
nous demandez on vous donne les
résultats vous serez prioritaire si vous
venez surtout et me demander une commune
ou une circonscription allez je remonte
un petit peu sur facebook
nous avons quatre qui nous demandent les
joueurs siat ou sa messe à metz allons-y
allons vous voulez des grandes villes
instant j'ai mais j'imagine qu'on a
premier plusieurs cerveaux conception
rien regarder 3 et wii alors on précise
sur les grandes communes sur les grandes
villes vous nous donnez si vous ne
pouvez si vous connaissez la
circonscription parce qu'il ya parfois
plusieurs circonscriptions à metz en
moselle première circonscription alors
on n'a pas les résultats allant voir si
on a dans la dans la deuxième non plus à
du mal à arriver un petit peu mais vous
savez ce que je vais faire je vais aller
chercher ça sur unistar de l'intérieur
qui nous demandent sa c4 c4 sur facebook
oui car alors dans la moselle et
première circonscription regardez ici on
n'a pas encore tous les résultats donc
les résultats que je vous indique sont
partielles ne vous emballez pas il aura
peut-être du changement mais sur une
base de 80 7% des électeurs et oui c'est
serré donc il faut faire encore
attention pour l'instant c'est le
rassemblement national qui en tête dans
la première circonscription devant
ensemble et devant la nuque mais c'est
bien parti pour le rn mais regardez il
ya à peine 500 voix d'écart sur les 13 %
de bulletins de vote à ouvrir encore il
y aura peut-être des surprises allez on
regarde quand même ce qui se passe dans
la deuxième là aussi c'est extrêmement
serré ensemble les rênes du ps on voit
que c'est une ville où tout le monde
peut se peut se qualifier au second tour
pour l'instant c'est encore très serré
et puis aller jamais deux sans trois
pour le prix de groupe troisième
circonscription à metz hélas pour
l'instant 44% des électeurs dont pour
l'instant c'est extrêmement partiel ne
vous fiez pas à 100 nous ne vous
donnerons pas de résultat sur cette
troisième circonscription est pour
l'instant le rn et bien et bien partie
est en tête mais rien n'est fait on
attendra un peu plus de dépouillement
je vais essayer d'aller chercher une
petite commis à j'aime bien les petites
communes parce que regarder ça c'est
baugé et on aime bien bougé alors on a
un petit problème d'image mais on aime
beaucoup bougé pour l'instant qui est la
plus jolie ville 1 le plus joli village
on a cherché le petit village vous
pouvez aussi si vous voulait nous donner
des noms de villes rigolo on avait fait
ce concours vous ce dont je me
souviendrai
vous voulez pas vous n'êtes pas grivois
allons-y on a autre chose oui donc on à
magny le hongre manie non aux petites
communes j'imagine alors m à g n y y
le hongre le
hijab ou regarder gelés on la trouve
magny le hongre magny le hongre à ça
nous intéresse pourquoi parce que nous
avons un ministre et grands cette
circonscription nous avons franck
riester qui était donc ici candidat si
je jeu mais il est encore un ministre
franck riester supérieur peut-être en
train de dire une bêtise
franck resta il a été ministre mais je
suis pas sûr qu'il le soit encore en
tout cas c'est une des figures de la
majorité ce que vous pouvez me chercher
ça en attendant adrien alors fonds créé
stérile et en tête à manier le monde
devant cédric colin et françois
lenormand de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et solidaire on va voir si on
a les résultats sur l'ensemble de l'âme
de la circonscription dans cette
circonscription de seine-et-marne c'est
la 5ème non pas sur le site du figaro
parce que tout n'est pas encore arrivé
mais vous savez qu'on peut aller sur le
site du ministère de l'intérieur franck
riester donc ministre délégué à ministre
délégué auprès de la ministre de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères
j'aimerais du commerce extérieur avril a
donc l'idée il est bien miné seine et
marne allons-y on trouve ça tout
doucement on est ici on a dit que
c'était la quatrième circonscription
cinquième pour franck riester on a les
résultats regarder franck riester oui il
est qualifié au second tour il sera face
à un candidat du rassemblement national
du ps n'a pas réussi à se qualifier
l'ailer non plus qui sont en difficulté
on n'a pas vu beaucoup de candidats et
l'eire qui à l'issue du second tour pour
l'instant depuis qu'on cherche en même
aucun sens - si je crois en a eu on en a
une on va rechercher savez quoi cela ils
vont pouvoir retrouver en replay et on
ira chercher ça dès qu'on aura fini ce
live donc franck riester est pour
l'instant en ballottage favorable
il a de l'avancé en plus face au
rassemblement national on imagine que le
report de voix lui sera favorable
allez je prends un commentaire de
jocelyne sur facebook à bonsoir je sais
juste qu'ils nous demandent
sully-sur-loire
sully-sur-loire ces jolies
sully-sur-loire aille bien à plusieurs
des succès sur loire allons-y jean-luc
riglet divers droite il est en tête dans
sept communes devant matt hill de pari
du rassemblement national kevin merlot
et 3e claude de ganay alors c'est
marrant merlot ganay
on est très dans l'ain dans la vigne
avec avec 7 cette circonscription
allons-y troisième circonscription du
loiret est ce qu on a les résultats
n'ont pas sur le site du figaro.fr mais
vous avez compris la méthode le
ministère de l'intérieur pour donc le
loiret et la troisième circonscription
est ce qu'on peut y aller oui troisième
circonscription du loiret est donc ici
c'est mathilde paris qui arrive en tête
et qui en ballottage favorable
elle sera au second tour face à la
candidate delà de la majorité
présidentielle carine barbier qui se
qualifie donc 7420 voix et la nuit ps
qui restent à quai troisième seulement
si 1814 nous aurons donc dans cette
circonscription ma chère jocelyne il me
semble oui jocelyne un duel entre le
rassemblement national est ensemble
faites votre choix la semaine prochaine
et puis vous renier comme ça on regarde
les résultats ensemble dites moi alors
j'avais repéré
ici c'est un commentaire qui étaient
retirés à des fois oui ils vont on
aurait pu on aurait pu mais pas parce
que les gens étaient mal poli quand même
on a que des internautes très
sympathique ce soir
alors nous reprendrons commentaires de
jimmy alors sur youtube bonsoir jean
bienvenu merci de nous écrire pontarlier
à pontarlier je comptais allons-y bien
sûr pontarlier je note que vous ne
m'avez encore pas donné de ville
bretagne d'habitude nous avons
favoritisme breton ce soir vous ne vous
retenez pas et j'attends les bretons
j'attends voyez je croyais qu'ils
étaient partout avec leurs drapeaux
reste que les bretons seraient en train
de nous décevoir jeu impossible
impossible sinon en israël est en tête
elle est déjà député hani genevard
devant philippe alpy d'ensemble e et un
bon score en regard des dents dans cette
commune dans cette commune de pontarlier
de martin lui dit du la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et solidaire allons
voir parce que ce qui nous intéresse
c'est ce qui se passe sur l'ensemble de
la circonscription nous n'avons pas
encore les résultats sur le site du
figaro mais on va évidemment trouver
tout ça donc dans cette 5e
circonscription du doubs on cherche par
ordre alphabétique évidemment c'est
facile 25 le doubs 5e circonscription et
donc annie genevard étant en ballottage
favorable est très bien partie vous avez
un
42,0 7% des voix devant donc le candidat
d'ensemble philippe alpy mais ce sera
difficile il reste huit petits points à
aller chercher pour à nouveau devenir
député pour annie genevard on sent
l'ancrage local pour pour la députée a
l'air voyez vous vous demandez s'il y
aurait des députés l air lines chance il
suffisait de il suffisait de demander
alors sur youtube on a beaucoup de
commentaires d'un coup merci à tous ceux
qui nous rejoint il arrive sur youtube
oui bien
rubel oui c'est frédéric aouine oms a
cru que c'était le pseudo non frédéric
beaucoup plus simple rubel alors comment
ça s'écrit comme ça est vue comme si ce
n'est être 2 l es exactement comme ça 77
et donc aux looks et est en tête
d'ensemble devant françois par adolphe
c'est une petite commune à un rebelle
et c'est donc la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale la nuque
mais ce qui est juste derrière un trois
voix d'écart entre entre les deux mais
ce qui nous intéresse ce qui intéresse
en août frédéric c'est le résultat à
l'échelle de la circonscription nous
n'avons pas le résultat en
seine-et-marne malheureusement dans
cette 1re circonscription mais vous avez
compris la manip on va chercher sur le
site du ministère de l'intérieur seine
et marne c'est très simple on descend
alors je suis allé un peu loin ici
première circonscription on trouve
ensemble en ballottage pour le second
tour extrêmement serré arnaud saint
martin de la nuit ps face à audruicq et
voilà le duel pour vous mon cher
frédéric au second tour vous faites
votre choix est il assez serré un regard
des 8400 27 voix pour l'un 8292 voix
pour l'autre vous avez vu personne n'a
eue les inscrits non non mais ils sont
tous les deux qualifiés puisqu'il faut
un second tour avec les deux premiers on
n'a pas encore eu de triangulaire vous
ne serez pas encore pas encore
j'aimerais bien aller voir quand même
rubel 1 vous en pensez quoi rubel ou
est-ce que c est ce que c'est joli c'est
petit village rue belle attention on
cherche on trouve on révise notre
géographie alors rubel on est oui on est
on est proche de de melun regardez rue
belle photo ah bah voilà on a bien fait
d'aller voir là on a bien fait d'aller
voir le mais c'est le château de
vaux-le-vicomte alors est-ce qu'on a
peut-être qu'on nous ment on n'est pas
vraiment arrivé alors doit pas être bien
loin en tout cas vous voyez ces
campagnes ars et bucolique ces
magnifiques vous voyez les tournesols ça
vous fait rêver il se tourne vers vous
parce que vous êtes le soleil mon cher à
rien le soleil de 7
cm à l'ére continue rien soleil qui oui
c'est ce qui se lève ou qui secoue je
pensais pas alors on a le mieux
commentaires supprimés est de retour a
donc va le prendre quoi oui c'est qu'ils
aient des fleurs d'oranger sur youtube à
l'orangé premier pseudo délicat et jolie
oui oui on avait fait ça ce qui m'a
également du plus beau pseudo et bien je
vous propose qu'on leur mette en jeu
fleur d'oranger parce que ça c'est
poétique fleur d'oranger le pseudo vous
êtes donc
en tête du plus joli pseudo fleur
d'oranger cette petite fleur à voir les
résultats de quelques communes
alors en fait c'est la précision elle
voulait préciser la circonscription
pardon dites nous dans laquelle se
trouve gagner à voir la huitième de
saintes de seine-saint-denis à gagny
alors oui j'ai à on peut déjà regardé
les résultats à gagny malheureusement on
n'a pas les résultats à gagny pour
l'instant puisque vous le savez
seine-saint-denis qui dit seine saint
denis dit région parisienne qui dit
région parisienne dit plus de monde dont
plus de monde et bien dépouillement plus
tardif et donc nous n'avons pas
forcément les résultats à l'heure gagner
dans la 8e circonscription
donc on peut aller voir sur ministère
l'intérieur si on a des résultats
partiels peut-être dans dance est dans
cette commune c'est difficile un parfois
dans les communes dans les départements
à la regarder ou est-ce que j'ai même
pas la seine-saint-denis 92 94 tiens
donc c'est très étonnant je n'ai pas les
résultats en seine saint denis pour
l'instant
seine et marne seine maritime alors on
va essayer de se renseigner pour quoi
pour l'instant nous n'avons pas les
résultats en seine-saint-denis machart
fleur d'oranger mais on va essayer de
régler ça tout de suite êtes vous donner
les résultats dès que possible à gagny
et dans cette circonscription on règle
le problème et on revient on trouve ça
tout de suite après en attendant
peut-être mais retire à itteville alors
je sais pas j'ai pas le jeu n'est pas le
département gîte ville
alors
je vais essayer aller 1 h allez je sens
le hin1 ce 2 t et de t on est presque
bon là je me suis planté c'est ça que
vous mettez ces 2 h qui vous a induit en
a mais j'ai joué hittites ville
exactement comme ceux ci nous sommes
dans le 91 l'essonne on a là on
exploiter ça va ou rejoignez on a eu un
peu de mal avec l'essonne au début du
live c'est le département allez savoir
pourquoi où les résultats ont le plus de
mal à arriver mais on a quand même les
résultats à itteville regarder avec la
candidate du rassemblement national
nathalie da conceicao carvalho qui est
en tête devant mathieu hilaire de la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
sociale on descend pour voir si on a les
résultats dans la circonscription c'est
la deuxième de l'essonne et oui on s'y
attendait un petit peu en a pas encore
les résultats allaient on essaie de
chercher ça sur le ministère de
l'intérieur essonne 2e circonscription
on a des résultats partiels ce qui peut
nous donner peut-être une première idée
70% des électeurs bonne idée même et
c'est très serré donc vous ne savez pas
encore mais on ne nous annonce pas pour
l'instant dans cette circonscription la
deuxième de l'essonne qui est au second
tour mais sachez avec la candidate du fn
est en tête pour l'instant de peu un
7755 voix contre 7089 pour le candidat
de la gauche de l'avenue ps matthieu
hilaire mais attention naïma siffert
d'ensemble n'a pas dit son dernier mot
6340 sur la base de 70 % des électeurs
inscrits ce sont des résultats
incomplets pour l'instant on précise
bien et donc ils seront disponibles
aussi sur notre moteur de recherche dans
la soirée évidemment oui alors je vous
propose qu'on va en récapitule ce qu'on
fait ici parce qu'il est 22h33 ya
peut-être des gens qui nous rejoignent
qui ont passé une soirée tranquille yves
c'est ils reviennent de l'apéro avec les
amis ils veulent savoir ce qu'on fait
ici ils veulent les résultats des
législatives comment fait adrien alors
c'est simple vous donc on rappelle qu'on
est en live donc à la fois sur facebook
sur le site lefigaro.fr sur youtube et
sur twitch a donc dans le chat ou
simplement sur les internautes peuvent
nous nous donner le soin le code postal
le nom de la commune ou bien la
circonscription et le département et
nous on a un moteur de recherche au
figaro qui est très bien fait on a
récupéré les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur exactement entre soit le
numéro le nom de la commune sur le code
postal soit la circonscription
directement de regarder cet essai nous
avons les résultats alors à tous parce
qu'on rappelle que et où ils arrivent au
fur et à mesure qu'une ville est grande
plus il ya de butin voilà donc forcément
on pose parce que vous donnez tout le
sud est et où il faut avoir les
résultats complets pour vous donner les
résultats dans certaines
circonscriptions mais on a trouvé une
petite astuce si on n'a pas encore tous
les résultats sur le site on va chercher
sur sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur comme ça vous savez tout et
puis on fait des petits concours aussi
alors sachez que pour l'instant si vous
nous rejoignez le plus joli nom de
village le plus joli village parce qu'on
va chercher des fois les photos baugé en
anjou avec un superbe château et puis le
pseudo le plus sympathique fleur
d'oranger fleurs vous attendez des
résultats alors l'un pour l'instant
c'est la seule personne karakar disons
un vrai pseudo oui mais on va essayer
d'en trouver le prénom on prend aussi
soin rites des jolis prénoms aussi bien
sûr alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir ici
alors clémentine sur facebook qui nous
demande et qu'après et clément après
fleur d'oranger clémentine vous avez une
un jeu même pas nous et c'est très
aromatique les agrumes alors clémentine
vous m'avez dit oui ray kay alors à
difficile comment on écrit est reconnu
et bachelet c'est tout simple recueil
c'est dans la sarthe sachez le bruno
pinson du rassemblement national est en
tête dans cette petite commune devant
dominique loup et éric martineau ça
c'est pour la commune mais nous ce qui
nous intéresse et les résultats dans la
circonscription j'imagine que clémentine
a envie de savoir dans la sarthe dont
qualifié pour le second tour bruno
pinson du rassemblement national c'est
très serré à 27,34 contre 26,05 pour le
candidat d'ensemble nous aurons donc un
second tour sans la nuit ps mais bien
avec le rassemblement national dominique
le lou doit s'incliner de la gauche pour
la gauche 8000 193 voix béatrice la
touche les républicains ne finit que
quatrième et puis vous pouvez chercher
un jusqu'en bas parce que c'est des
petits candidats aussi henri noël
regarder 180 une voix on connaît pas
henri noël mais on le salue
alors est-ce qu'on peut aller à saint
martin d'hères c'est une demande de
françois sur facebook vos désirs sont
des ordres saint martin d'hères c'est
pas dans l'isère ce à saint martin
d'hères 1 alors peut-être c'est comme ça
et tu peux te exactement là il y avait
bien un achat vous voyez ça martin
d'hères c'est très joli saint martin
d'hères j'irai vous montrer tout à
l'heure un bon jeu we see me sens que
c'est pas mal
toutes les communes sont superbes en
france vous savez cyrielle châtelain et
très bon score pour cela le châtelain de
la nuit ps 42 92 % des voix ensemble
jean-charles cola roi est deuxième et
puis chloé bailly du rassemblement
national
saint martin d'hères on est dans la 2e
circonscription de l'isère et donc nous
avons un second tour de cette danse est
2e circonscription de l'isère vous le
voyez entre cyrielle châtelain de la
nuit ps et jean charles que l'ars oi
d'ensemble c'est assez serré 1 33%
contre contre 28 il ya environ 2000 voix
d'écart pour l'instant chloé bailly du
rassemblement national est éliminé
fabienne sahara et est assez loin et
allez on va voir saint martin d'hères
quand même si mahmud eh oui c'est un mot
c'est si joli si joli que vous
prétendiez je ne peux pas me braquer
avec les habitants de saint martin
d'hères mais comme on les appelle les
allées chercher voilà c'est en banlieue
de grenoble on a une jolie petite wii
regardez regardez moi ce paysage à saint
martin d'hères je n'ai que l'hymne du
mûrier vous seriez pas bien là très
franchement j'ai c'est là on a on a 3 3
belles communes déjà oui mais on a
beaucoup aimé pour l'instant le château
de baugé en anjou on va pas se mentir
pendant ce temps on est assez épaté par
baugé en anjou là on est sur un paysage
plus montagnards vous avait autre chose
à me proposer de faire du tourisme parce
qu'il ya des gens qui attendent des
résultats à mon cher alors sur youtube
[Musique]
à des rythmes en chercher sur le premier
tour des législatives alors n'oubliez
pas de nous demander délais les
résultats chez vous un dante dans les
communes oui parce que on rappelle que
le débat et la grande soirée des
législatives c'est également sur le site
du figaro.fr c'est avec bruno dresse
avec vincent où vous avez toutes les
analyses toutes les réactions d'autres
score si vous le souhaitez et puis des
débats mais nous ce qu'on fait c'est
vous aider vous donner les résultats
dans votre commune dans votre
circonscription pour pouvoir choisir la
semaine prochaine alors j'ai pas de j'ai
pas de petites communes mais sur youtube
en elle-même lors qu'ils nous demandent
avignon avignon on peut tenter allons
voir avignon avignon avignon on y danse
on y danse sur le pont d'avignon nous on
n'a pas les résultats avignon mais
première circonscription du vaucluse je
vous propose qu'on aille voir peut-être
ça me paraît difficile si on a déjà pas
les résultats et l'union et sur le site
du ministère de l'intérieur on peut
essayer de d'avoir une idée peut-être de
ce qui se passe dans le vaucluse le 84
première circonscription au regard des
résultats incomplets parce qu'il ya pour
l'instant moins de 40% des électeurs
donc on ne vous donne pas de premières
estimations on attend un petit peu mais
avignon on peut toujours aller chercher
d'ici une petite heure ça devrait st
bées au fur et à mesure et alors que
françoise vient à notre rescousse
thibault j'étais en train de chercher le
nom des habitants de saint martin
d'hères ouais et sachez que on les
appelle les martinérois les martinérois
voyez une forme de logique merci la
france merci france vous avez bien
raison de préciser parce que ça nous
intéresse vraiment les martinérois et on
salue tous les martinérois qui ont donc
eux qui auront donc à choisir au
deuxième tour entre un candidat
d'ensemble est un candidat de l'ani pas
si alors on avait beau mon mais on y est
déjà allé si légalement qu'est ce que je
peux vous prendre il ya beaucoup de
monde ce que je vois vous avez du mal à
choisir ouais alors la courneuve
peut-être la courneuve on peut choisir
la cour non on peut trouver la courneuve
peut-être dans le 93 où c'est qu'on a eu
des soucis dans le 93 c'est bizarre on
n'a pas tous les résultats mais à la
courneuve très bon score 42 92 % pour
soumia bourg ou à de la nuque baisse
devant un candidat divers vous le voyez
à l'idiot haras
et devant encore un divers gauche
ensemble est dans le dur dans cette dans
cette ville de la courneuve la courneuve
dans quelle circonscription et on la
quatrième de seine-saint-denis on n'a
malheureusement pas les résultats et
j'ai vu qu'on n'avait pas les résultats
pour l'instant sur le ministère matin on
va voir si ça s'est réglé mais je vous
laisse en attendant me trouvais me
donner une autre commune si vous voulez
oui alors à l'instant sur facebook nous
avons tilelli qui nous demandent
montmagny montmagny et tout est remanié
tout est alors regardez
100g réactualiser la page et suivre et
de faire ça la courneuve on est dans la
je regarde dans quelle circonscription à
4e circonscription de et bien dans les
résultats regardez
soumis à bora qui est en tête
36% des suffrages devant azzedine taibi
divers gauche voilà comme ça on a un peu
plus de précisions sur le ministère de
l'intérieur donc on aura un duel au
second tour entre la nuit ps la gauche
réunie et un candidat divers gauche
peut-être peut-être qui n'a pas été
investi par le parti socialiste et ses
et c'est souvent un ces cas là des
candidats dissidents voilà vous avez les
résultats dans la 4e circonscription de
seine-saint-denis on devra choisir entre
la nuque baisse et un candidat divers
gauche la semaine prochaine
alors je retourne un peu sur youtube oui
allons je vais prendre le commentaire de
thibault a très joli prénom alors à ut a
eu à le dénoncer a eu d abord un peu
loin de leurs à un pur ah oui plus rares
mais je vous salue mon cher thibault dit
moi
alors je ne sais pas comment on prononce
un thibault il faut il faut m'excuser
alors c'est wissous vis ou je ne sais
pas c'est sain d'efforts w a fait un
effort revanchard la wii2 est so us
wissous où vivent un salon avez vous
savez soit d'ibos dit nous dit mme
thibault comment on prononce wissous vi
où on est dans l'essonne malheureusement
on n'a pas les résultats c'est dans la
sixième circonscription ce que je vous
propose c'est qu'on aille voir on va
essayer de chercher et on l'a dit
l'essonne qui est le département où les
résultats le plus de mal à arriver
jusqu'ici 6e circonscription de regarder
- deux des 40 % des électeurs inscrits
pour l'instant dans les dépouillements
donc on ne peut malheureusement pas vous
donner mon cher thibault les résultats à
wissous bis où il nous dit nous fait un
petit message pour savoir comment on
prononce on continue oui alors pour
l'instant j'ai rien d'autre sur youtube
non mais alors je suis sûr que vous
allez trouver ça sur lefigaro.fr
peut-être sur facebook peut-être même
sur twitter parce qu'il ya devant nous
sur twitter j'ai vous pouvez donc nous
demander des résultats on pourra même
aller chercher si vous le souhaitez les
résultats dans des circonscriptions qui
intéressent l'ensemble des français je
pense à celles où on peut trouver des
ministres par exemple est-ce que
elisabeth bornes vont gagner
tranquillement son son élection la
première élection pour l on peut tout
vous donnez vous nous faites un petit
message à leur enième transmet et puis
moi je cherche ici comme je peux est-ce
qu'on a autre chose alors pour l'instant
nous n'avons rien d'autant que là je
vais me permettre de demander les
résultats
de la commune dans laquelle je suis né
la raison faites-vous plaisir
en bretagne voilà c'est vrai donc c'est
vous qui portez la bretagne ce soir
alors que c'est l'abus de suite c'est
très fervente vous savez quoi on ira
même regarder les photos de votre petit
village de naissance on fera ça alors
c'est peut-être pas aussi beau que ce
qu'on a eu
bon alors dites moi ne faites pas durer
le suspense ça s'appelle ploemeur
ploemeur oui ce serait bon comme ça un
très bon ton pleut exact mais j'ai senti
vous avez une très belle prononciation
vous savez alors à ploemeur ronan loas
ce divers droite il est en tête pour
l'instant devant damien girard delà de
la nuque ps voilà pour cette commune de
ploemeur l'isad métayer deux ensembles
est en troisième position allons voir
sur l'ensemble de la circonscription
parce que ça ça vous ça vous intéresse
sans doute 5e circonscription du
morbihan et donc damien girard de la nu
ps est en tête 31 47 % des voix devant
lysiane métayer d'ensemble nous aurons
donc un second tour entre et bien le
camp de jean luc mélenchon et le camp de
emmanuel macron dans votre commune de
plomeur ce que faisait l'autre jour mais
je vous en prie bras je voulais promise
chose promise chose due nous allons voir
les photos de ploemeur parce que je suis
sûr que c'est réussi au bord de la mer
non à s'est pas allié à écrire alors
n'ont en revanche que vous balancez
regarder alors c'est à je vois oui je le
vois où le village ici et donc on le
fort de chiara gagnent 10 fort-bloqué
exactement est en fait alors je clique
là dessus j'imagine ça ça a l'air très
beau ah oui à ces superbes a là aussi
vous un paysage très breton oui mais
alors là vous avez un peu souvent dû
votre petit village où mais ce n'est pas
forcément très joli on est oui c'est
comme quand on raconte une blague c'est
l'effet de surprise oui on veut pas dire
j'ai une blague super hâte raconté je
veux dire j'ai une blague et puis est ce
qu'on prend un bain c'est très joli
ploemeur donc là on est au fort de kerra
gagnent 10 fort bloqué magnifique
d'accord il va vous inviterez pour les
vacances non alors n'est pas cette fois
j'ai bien compris vous êtes d'accord bon
allez est-ce qu'on a autre chose on a
des gens qui ne montrent peut-être les
résultats chez eux parce que sinon moi
aussi je vais commencer à
donner des résultats pour savoir où je
joue je veux avoir débat lorsque alors
là on est on est on a la mer et vous
aussi vous vous êtes a alors deux autres
oui de sa voix me vous savez quoi je
vais aller chercher les résultats dans
l'est dans les hautes-alpes c'est moi
j'aime bien les hautes-alpes j'y suis né
fine à briançon si vous voulez tout
savoir à lons et donc je vous propose
qu'on qu'on cherche les résultats s'ils
voulaient la commune de mes grands
parents voilà réotier c'est un petit
village c'est magnifique réotier dans le
dans le 05 et joël giraud il est il est
temps il est en tête dans cette danse
est comme une fois qu'on a eu les
résultats d'ailleurs tout à l'heure et
puis je vais vous montrer quand même
réussi parce que je suis sûr que c'est à
lui que c'est un sujet complet à
ploemeur weir et outils contre ploemeur
fait faites votre choix et puis surtout
vous nous donnez des jeans celle que
vous voulez chercher évidemment sur sur
sur lefigaro.fr sur youtube regardez la
fontaine pétrifiante je dois je dois
avouer que c'est très beau et ça ça vous
en bouche un coin vous voyez pas ça
partout n'ont pas été capables mars s
voilà voilà voilà en effet regardez moi
se passe dans les hautes-alpes ce petit
cette petite photo c'est le fort devant
dauphin là bas au fond monté par vauban
si vous voulez tout savoir et je vous
conseille si vous faites un peu de vélo
je vous avez une très belle cuisse
d'aller faire du vélo dans les
hautes-alpes c'est magnifique espace à
autre chose oui alors sur youtube on a
quatre gtv bonjour quel gtv drôle de
pseudo demande
résultats province par donc la ville de
christian jacob ah oui bah oui ça nous
intéresse que fait le président sortant
puisqu'il ne se représentera pas des
républicains à provins regarder isabelle
perrigault à mais ce n'est pas lui oui
oui il ne se présente pas évidemment et
qu' on ne peut pas le trouver il avait
loupé rigodon qui prend la place de
christian jacob elle est en tête la
candidate des républicains avec 33
points 53% devant le candidat de l'ani
baisse et celui du rassemblement
national c'est très serré il ya deux
petites voix d'écart dans cette commune
de province et alors qu'on peut ce qu'on
peut voir c'est évidemment les résultats
dans cette 4e circonscription de
seine-et-marne c'est plus difficile sur
l'ensemble de la circonscription pour
isabelle perrigault mais elle est quand
même qualifié au second tour avec
aymeric du rock du rassemblement
national nous aurons donc un second tour
entre le fn et les républicains tiens
donc ni ensemble ni la du ps c'est une
circonscription un peu étonnante par
rapport à tout ce qu'on a pu voir que
c'est la première fois qu'on a on a ce
cas de figure exactement
allez toujours sur youtube on a une
question de frédéric pensez vous que le
fn est en ballottage favorable à saint
tropez du fait qu eric zemmour n'est pas
qualifié pour ce second tour et blanc on
peut aller voir saint tropez allons-y
alors c'est vrai que
eric zemmour on n'est pas qualifiés au
second tour de très peu un dans ce dans
cette circonscription il est quand même
arrivé en tête à saint tropez régler mon
regard des reconquêtes alors j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure que dans le sud
de la circonscription au bord de la mer
j'ai fait un très bon score et au nord
c'est le rn qui avait tiré les marrons
du feu eric zemmour 37,12 % dans dans
cette commune de saint tropez il y a
fait le gendarme a probablement sereine
mauborgne ensemble et est en deuxième
position et donc allons voir sur cette
4e circonscription du var on n'a pas les
résultats sur le site du figaro.fr mais
je vous assure qu'on va les trouver on
va les trouver ici sur le site du
ministère de l'intérieur 4e
circonscription et donc ses rennes
mauborgne est en tête pour ensemble elle
est en ballottage favorable pour
l'instant face à philippe lottiaux le
candidat du r'n et donc on peut voir
qu'eric zemmour ne s'est pas qualifié au
second tour puisqu'il n'a pas atteint 12
5% des inscrits et qu' il perd donc pour
aller 800 voix à boxer ça nous permet
chaire thibault de répondre à la
question de ses matches sur youtube donc
il nous demande si on peut rappeler dans
quel cas il ya une triangulaire donc
c'est un bon exemple puisqu'ici l'eau il
aurait fallu comme vous le disiez
thibault keynote zemmour face 12 5% des
inscrits et pas des ces cinq là on voit
qu'il a 18 66% oui parce que la tension
très forte comme partout en france voilà
et est donc ici philippe lottiaux quand
bien même il n'a réuni que 11,38 % des
inscrits passe forcément second tour
parce qu'il faut bien un deuxième
candidat bien sûr pour le second tour il
ne peut pas y avoir de second tour sans
candidat ou avec un seul candidat voilà
pourquoi nous avons et on suivra ce à un
deuxième tour entre philippe lottiaux du
r n est certainement bornes d'ensemble
eric zemmour donc est éliminé et le
report de voix et bien ce sera
intéressant peut-être que philippe
lottiaux al'avantage avec ce quand même
bon score en troisième position d'eric
zemmour imagination ne devrait pouvoir
récupérer une bonne partie de ces voix
là mais on suivra sa 4ème
circonscription du var la semaine
prochaine allons-y donc aller sur le
site un nouvel arrivant oui mathieu
carpentier bonjour mathieu monde les
résultats à vauréal vous ré avec mon et
chris v avait a eu r e exacte et mère je
les regardais vauréal c'est dans le val
d'oise aurélien tâches et à aurélien
tâche et personnalités intéressantes
anciennement macro nist qui a quitté le
parti et qui est donc désormais sous la
bannière de la nuit ps 31 47 % à vauréal
devant victorien l'achat d'ensemble et
richard durand du rassemblement national
mais on descend pour savoir sur
l'ensemble de la circonscription c'est
aurélien taché est aussi en tête nous
n'avons pas les résultats ici mais vous
avez bien compris la mécanique le site
du ministère de l'intérieur le val
d'oise on descend un tout petit peu et
on va trouver ça le val d'oise ici 95 4e
circonscription il me semble que cette
séance est la dixième douzième année les
résultats ne sont pas complets mais un
est pas complet du tout alors ne vous
basez pas pour l'instant sur ses
résultats mais après avec 49% des
électeurs inscrits 1 / sur les
dépouillements nous voyons qu'aurélien
taché est en tête mais de très peu
devant victorien l'achat d'ensemble et
richard durand du rn petite avance mais
rien n'est fait on ne vous annonce pas
officiellement qu'aurélien taché est au
second tour même si il est bien parti
voilà on va n que le
moteur de recherche de vidéos est
accessible à tous donc si vous voulez
avoir les résultats définitifs plus tard
dans la soirée ou même demain matin vous
pouvez aller sur le site du figaro.fr on
remonte un peu il ya quatre j'ai
toujours sur youtube
enfin je veux dire on retourne sur
youtube qui nous allons scinder d'un
province et qui nous demande noyen sur
seine à noyen-sur-seine
allons-y noyen-sur-seine
j'imagine que ça s'est fait comme ça
avec ah ah ah je me suis trompé noyen
sur seine hop bien sûr certains sur
scène on va sur scène donc en seine et
marne mathieu garnier est en tête devant
isabelle perrigault et aymeric du rock
c'est oui c'est vrai qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure les résultats dans cette
circonscription et on vous rappelle donc
aymeric du rox du rassemblement national
isabelle perry beau des républicains
sont tous les deux qualifiés au second
tour dans cette dans cette
circonscription l'ancienne
circonscription de christian jacob le
président sortant des républicains qui
ne se représente pas comme candidat pour
les lrs qu'on a autre chose alors pour
l'instant non pas de nouveau commenté
alors j'ai monté un petit peu oui bien
sûr vous pouvez retrouver ça j'en suis
sûr beaucoup de franciliens ce soir
c'est vrai ce qui est très bien
alors ils nous demandent les résultats
hier allié à willow rivières gard y est
oui le hier de nicolas dupont aignan
exact c'est ça que vous voulez savoir
dans le 91 dans l'essonne alors est ce
que nicolas dupont aignan fait un bon
score à hyères pour l'instant on n'a pas
les résultats dans sa commune on peut
voir que nicolas dupont aignan et dans
la 8e circonscription de l'essonne
allons-y allons voir sur le site du
ministère de l'intérieur dans l'essonne
8e circonscription ce sont des résultats
partiels donc même lorsque je vais vous
montrer les résultats ils ne sont pas
officiels mais nous pouvons voir donc
qu'avec cette base faible pour l'instant
d'un dépouillement à hauteur de 42% des
électeurs inscrits bien sachez que
nicolas dupont aignan et en seconde
position c'est très serré pour l'instant
avec 27 points 68 28 % des suffrages
derrière la candidate de la nuque baisse
mais mohamed ben hida pour ensemble n'a
pas dit son dernier mot regardez 3965
voit pour l'instant c'est très proche de
nicolas dupont aignan donc c'est encore
serré on n'est même pas à la moitié du
dépouillement de 10 des électeurs
inscrits donc pour l'instant nicolas
dupont aignan n'a pas un boulevard est
ce qu'on peut dire et on suivra
évidemment ce qui se passe dans cette
huitième circonscription de l'essonne
allons-y alors je vois pas nouveau
commentaire donc on peut peut-être
retourner dans une commune qu'on nous a
demandé tout à l'heure oui bien sûr je
si ça vous va thibault et jette le chef
ici jeu
je me souviens vous avez demandé avignon
n'avait pas eu de résultats à avignon
oui oui oui et vous pensez qu'on a les
résultats avignon maintenant c'est un
autre jour mais n'ont toujours pas
toujours pas à avignon malheureux
démenti non non non alors ce qu'on peut
faire vous savez quoi on va si vous le
voulez bien et vous vous continuez à
nous donner les résultats chez vous
parce que vous n'hésitez pas si vous
êtes un peu timide vous nous trouvez
tags ou venez chercher oui c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est vrai on vous prend vous
écoute et on vous donne les résultats ce
que ça vous intéresse d'aller chercher
les résultats par exemple pour des
ministres tient gérald darmanin dans la
10e circonscription du nord est ce qu'on
peut se trouver ça le nord parce qu'on
n'est pas allé d'ailleurs
circonscription dit ça ya beaucoup de
circonscriptions d'ailleurs vous avez vu
dans le nord nord circonscription 10 n'a
malheureusement pas encore les résultats
dans cette circonscription mais on va
essayer de trouver ça sur le site du
ministère de l'intérieur tient aussi du
ministère de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
vous faites des liens le nord donc
allons voir où en est gérald darmanin
dans cette dans cette élection
législative 10e circonscription du nord
il est en tête assez largement
d'ailleurs regardez 39,11 % des
suffrages exprimés
11960 voix il sera face au second tour
est une candidate de la nuque est leslie
mortreux duels donc entre la majorité
ensemble et là nue ps dans cette
circonscription mais gérald darmanin est
très très bien parti dans cette élection
législative est-ce qu'on a quelqu'un
d'autre ou est ce qu'on cherche d'autres
cirques d'autres george à non jean
priorité les pattes commune mais j'ai
des circonscriptions amsalem bien
allons-y un pseudo efficace simple sur
youtube c'est ce frenchy the frenchy qui
les revenus qu'ils nous demandent deal
français est un français dans le dans la
12e circonscription des hauts de seine
hauts de seine alors hauts-de-seine
région parisienne et donc une fois de
plus on ne peut rien promettre un dans
ce genre de circonscription parce que en
région parisienne les bureaux de vote
ferment plus tard sur des plus grandes
communes dépouillement plus long n'avons
malheureusement pas les résultats sur le
site du figaro mais allons voir si on a
des résultats partiels sur le ministère
le site du ministère de l'intérieur 92
les hauts-de-seine allons-y vous m'avez
dit 12e circonscription 12e ça et non
pas de résultats encore dans la 12e
circonscription à l'origine également la
10e et la 10e on a des résultats
partiels the frenchy regardait la 10e
elle nous intéresse tout
particulièrement parce c'est gabriel
attal ah oui très bon score il a frôlé
alors il peut encore parce que regarder
ce sont des résultats incomplets donc
des votes des bulletins vont encore
tomber mais gabriel attal alors on se
parle obtient
49,79 % des voix le ministre du budget
une liste des comptes publics un ancien
porte parole du gouvernement très
médiatique gabriela talent est à deux
doigts d'être qualifiés directement
après le premier tour n'a pas encore eu
de candidat calicéo premier donné on n'a
pas encore vu il me semble mais pour
l'instant si ça continue comme ça si les
voix continuent à tomber dans
l'escarcelle de gabriella talent le
ministre des comptes publics pourraient
donc se qualifier directement au second
de directement direct dès le premier
tour de devenir député donc voilà
intéressant ce qui se passe dans la
10ème circonscription des hauts-de-seine
pour un ministre qui devrait être élu
assez facilement si c'est pas cette
semaine ça devrait être une formalité la
semaine prochaine en deuxième position
c'est donc cécile souffle et de la
noblesse on sait qu'on l'a autre chose
ou on cherche d'autres mineurs sur
youtube nous avons ces matches qui nous
demandent les résultats à kano
qui se prononce comme ça ca n o 1 h le
sh100 canohès canaris ciani oui oui mais
là j'ai bien compris que vous étiez en
train de ramer mon chat adrien canoë
canohès dans les pyrénées-orientales
sophie blanc est en tête du
rassemblement national devant romain
grau d'ensemble et devant francis d'ascq
de la nuque ps s'est serrée 1 mais on
peut peut-être essayer de voir ce qui se
passe sur l'ensemble de la
circonscription
allons-y alors on est dans la première
circonscription des pyrénées-orientales
et on a donc des résultats nous aurons
un deuxième tour entre le rassemblement
national de sophie blanc et ensembles de
romain grau la majorité présidentielle
qui se qualifie donc ici et francis
daspe est il n'est pas passé à grand
chose à regarder 300 voix moins de 300
voix mais la nouvelle vision populaire
écologique et solidaire ne sera donc pas
au second tour ici alors il sent qu'on
peut regarder et on peut voir les
résultats dans des précédentes années
vous pouvez trouver ça regardez par
exemple en 2017 romain grau en marche
c'est lui qui avait été élu à
l'assemblée nationale donc il est quand
même un petit peu en difficulté romain
grau puisqu'il arrive en deuxième
position dans ce premier tour nous
verrons s'il réussit à conserver son
siège de député mais pas triangulaire
sinon la première question de ces matchs
non non non pas du tout savoir il y
avait une triangulaire non parce que
français dassault n'a pas dû réussir à
atteindre et n'a pas réussi à atteindre
12 5 % des inscrits avec une abstention
vous le voyez dans les
pyrénées-orientales et dense est dans
cette commune de
54,38 % dans cette circonscription
première circonscription des
pyrénées-orientales
toujours sur youtube à huy a de nouveau
zoo frenchy à l'eau il aime à savoir si
aymeric caron alors aymeric caron quelle
circonscription du
xviiie arrondissement
excellente qui sourit alors là et bien
je suis sûr que vous allez pouvoir
trouver ça alors vous avez sur le site
du
figaro.fr le figaro.fr regarder on va le
trouver ensemble vous avez un site avec
les points chauds un les 100 points
chauds à
surveiller et je sais que vous pouvez me
trouver cela la commune d'aymeric
d'aymeric caron vous avez aussi regarder
les résultats la carte des candidats
arrivés en tête au premier tour ça on
peut le trouver cette carte qui se
remplit petit à petit alors à parier
pour l'instant paris on a du mal à voir
les résultats ce que vous pouvez me
trouver ça me dire c'est la 10ème
circonscription des biens alors voilée
on va aller chercher ça je pense qu'on
va aller directement sur le site du
ministère de l'intérieur dix huitième
circonscription paris évidemment avec
des résultats qui arrivent plus tard on
vous a expliqué pourquoi bien sûr alors
paris est ce que j'ai des résultats déjà
à paris quelques pas ici et c'est un
petit peu difficile alors paris pour
l'instant je les ai pas on va essayer
quand même sur le sur le site paris 10e
vous m'avez 10/18 lanton bien
7e circonscription
celui-ci reconception 18 et
malheureusement non nous n'avons pas les
résultats leur nom 18e regarder ces
pierre-yves bournazel pour entraînements
sont également évidemment
aymeric caron maintenant pour l'instant
on n'a malheureusement pas les résultats
mais vous savez pourquoi il est que
22h59 et les résultats par y arriver un
peu plus tard mais oui ça nous intéresse
café aymeric caron lui qui se lance en
politique évidemment l'ancien
journaliste
j'ai un breton à surfer alors on s'amuse
parce que on vous attendait les bretons
adrien vous attendez il sentait un peu
seul allons-y donc guingamp à guingamp
en avant
guingamp vial était un peu facile je
vous le conseille je vous l'accord
yannick kerlogot il est en tête à
guingamp c'est le seul candidat de
ensemble il devance muriel les braults
de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale et le
rassemblement national arrive troisième
allons voir ce qui se passe sur
l'ensemble de la circonscription c'est
la quatrième des côtes d'armor et donc
voyaient leurs veaux qui est en tête
dans queens je crois qu'on avait vu sept
cette circonscription tout à leur foi
que c'est la première qu'on a chargé le
nom et qu'on était allé en bretagne à
muriel lèvres au qui est donc qualifié
au second tour
yannick kerlogot tu es deuxième nous
aurons donc un duel serré un vous voyez
qu'il ya 600 voix d'écart au premier
tour entre le candidat qui essaiera de
d'amener jean luc mélenchon au poste de
premier ministre et celui qui soutient
emmanuel macron dans sa présidence
sur youtube on a toujours 4g qui qui qui
est un qui nous est fidèle ce soit un
bienvenu merci de te roh moo-hyun alors
alors oui vous nous met en difficulté
montereau comme ça ressemble rixe vous
l'avez a besoin parce que moteur de
recherche oui il est très fort que moi
alors regarder parce que à montereau
fault yonne très bons scores de la nuit
passée le dit jérôme delgado elle est
devant jean louis thiériot de l'est
républicain et le rassemblement national
juste derrière ensemble ensemble
ensemble pas ensemble un ici alors
peut-être que jean louis thiériot était
protégé par parents semblent pas de
candidats ensemble en tout cas dans
cette circonscription mais allons voir
dans cette troisième circonscription de
seine-et-marne eh bien nous aurons un
deuxième tour entre elodie jérôme
delgado de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale et jean louis
thiériot des républicains pas de
qualification pour dominique lui aurait
dû rassemblement national ça joue à pas
grand-chose et 500 voix et oui c'est
vrai que c'est pas beaucoup mais avec
une aussi forte abstention et bien voilà
la candidate du rassemblement national
n'est pas au second tour 2e tour donc
entre lanuf s et les républicains c'est
serré également 400 voix d'écart à peine
au premier tour dans cette troisième
circonscription de seine-et-marne
alors j'ai pas de nouvelles communes
pour l'instant mais vous savez ça va
faire on va chercher à nouveau nos nos
petits ministre fait savoir si les
banques ont
effectivement
oui surtout on est là pour vous avant
tout pour que vous puissiez nous donner
et trouver les résultats chez vous
damien abad ça vous intéresse et à la
voiture de la polémique il ya quelques
semaines il était donc damien abad dans
l'ain dans la 5e circonscription de l'un
est ce que nous avons des résultats oui
alors regardez damien abad toujours
marqué divers droite damien abad
qualifié pour le pour le second tour 33
points 38% des suffrages il sera face à
florence pisani de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale le
rassemblement national échoue à la
troisième place les républicains avec
julien martinez font moins de 10% et on
note on note donc que damien abad est
bien parti pour rester député malgré les
polémiques malgré sa défection des
républicains il est en bonne posture
l'ancrage
locale semble fonctionner pour le
ministre des solidarités de l'autonomie
et du handicap qui est damien abad vous
me dites si on a une autre si on aide et
d'autres questions pour d'autres
communes
je cherche d'autres d'autres candidats à
l'est par exemple
brigitte bourguignon tient dans la 6ème
du pas de calais allons voir pas de
calais brigitte bourguignon qui est donc
vous le savez ministre de la santé c'est
elle qui a remplacé olivier ferrand et
donc elle est qualifiée au second tour
mais alors là attention
deuxième tour sous tension pour la
ministre de la santé parce que 32 10
pour cent des voix juste devant
christine engrand qui est la candidate
du rassemblement national avec 30 points
33% des voix oui on sait que le nord le
pas de calais ce sont des terres qui
sont acquises depuis quelques années à
marine le pen est au rassemblement
national et donc nous aurons un deuxième
tour serré parce qu'il ya moins de 1000
voix d'écart après le premier tour nous
verrons sur qui se reportent les
électeurs de pascale lebecque était le
candidat de la new tech et qui a fait 15
points 98 % nous suivrons sa tout
particulièrement pour savoir si brigitte
bourguignon et l'emportent parce que
c'est important si brigitte bourguignon
ne l'emportent pas elle perd son poste
depuis sinistrés que j'avais c'est la
règle c'est la règle c'est la règle
voulue par emmanuel macron
aller on a un commentaire sur facebook
c'est marie rose qui nous demandent ma
chambre marie-rose marsan tiens donc
allons-y marzan alors mars en vrai ce
que ça peut bien être dans le 56 en
argent c'est le morbihan ils sont là les
bretons ça y est ils débarquent en force
alors un régionaliste est en test paul
molac
il est donc en tête dans sept communes
de marquion avec 31 33% des voix devant
léa le flécher qui est donc deuxième
c'est la candidate de la nuque ps
florent de kersauson tiens donc vous
rappelle quelque chose ce nom qui à 2
419 21% pour le rassemblement national
rosen guégan pour ensemble c'est assez
serré mais c'est une petite commune
d'arzon on va voir ce qui se passe sur
l'ensemble de la circonscription un
quatrième circonscription du morbihan et
donc paul molac y qualifie qualifié pour
le second tour est assez facilement en
plus sain il fait un très bon score 21
mille neuf cent voix face à rosenberg
ans qui donc lui passe tout juste
regarder
18,26 % contre 18,1 je fais le calcul 30
voix 30 voix ouais ouais un peu un peu
plus de 30 voix il me semble mais voilà
trente cinq voix d'écart mais c'est donc
le candidat de la majorité qui équipent
astien allons voir qui était le député
est ce que c'était déjà paul molac dans
cette dans cette circonscription oui
j'ai regardé il était en marche et il
n'y a plus il n'était donc plus il
n'était donc plus candidat en marche
mais mais visiblement il déplaît à ses
électeurs qui ont décidé de le mettre
largement en tête dans ce premier tour
même s'il n'est pas qualifié directement
comme c'était le cas il ya cinq ans
je n'ai pas de nouvelles communes si
vous donc on peut peut-être trouvé un
ami me
rappeler aux gens ce qu'on fait ici et
comment on peut faire pour nous poser
des questions alors tout simplement
on est en direct donc sur le on utilise
un moteur de recherche qui est sur le
site du figaro.fr on reçoit les
résultats du premier tour des
législatives au fur et à mesure et vous
pouvez nous demande et donc les
résultats dans votre commune ou dans vos
doux ou dans votre circonscription on
peut faire les deux évidemment je vous
rappelle qu'on est en live donc sur le
figaro.fr sur facebook sur youtube et
sur twitter donc vous avez 4 chat donc
n'hésitez pas
on prend les questions voilà vraiment on
a on a quelques concours oui on a
quelques concours tient d'ailleurs on
était je vous rappelle on était dans
quelle commune là on était à hamar sens
il me semble un c'est ça oui je crois
qu'on était à marzan tient allons voir
marc censi c'est joli et où on peut
trouver marzan parce que ça ça nous
intéresse donc dans le morbihan on a dit
alors gens lèvent quand même
l'ancienne commune que nous étions allés
voir réotier dans les hautes-alpes
marsan donc allons-y marzan et bien
c'est évidemment au bord de la mer tout
proche de la mer près de vannes et donc
on peut voir quelques petites fautes au
regard des marchands la mer c'est la
bretagne ça c'est votre
salon n'est pas tout à fait au bord de
la mer oui je sais mais vous êtes un
privilégié vous adorez mars en mars en
données sur au bord d'un petit canal
tiens qu'est ce que c'est que ce cours
d'eau là on peut peut-être trouvé ça
alors attendez dites nous un dit nous
pont de la roche bernard quelle est
cette cette rivière là on n'a pas d'info
ici mais on va trouver ça on va trouver
ça évidemment est-ce qu'on a une autre
commune ou est ce qu'on cherche les
ministres on peut chercher les ministres
en attendant qu'on ait d'ozil alors deux
lettres qu'on peut voir ce qui a fait
elisabeth bord quand même c'est la
première ministre on n'est pas encore à
les voir aller dans la sixième
circonscription du calvados on peut
trouver ça ne tient à dos allons-y
elisabeth borne à les qualifier pour le
second tour ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour elle un puisque c'est sa première
tentative d'élections sa première fois
qu'elle se présente la première ministre
assez largement en tête devant nos égos
charles le bien nommé pour le las nubes
24 53 % des voix nous aurons donc un
duel entre la majorité présidentielle et
la nuit pence porté par jean luc
mélenchon qui porte jean luc mélenchon
c'est vous qui voyez jean philippe roy
du rassemblement national il n'est pas
qualifié au second tour il échoue à un
peu plus de 1000 voix pour pour se
qualifier dans une triangulaire on n'a
pas encore vu triangulaire de puits a
depuis le début de ce live est donc
elisabeth bornes et au second tour
sachez le on suivra ça la semaine
prochaine on a d'autres questions qui
seront cherche alors si vous voulez en
faire une petite pause après un ca vous
me dites est ce qu'on peut regarder ce
que fait peut-être amélie de montchalin
on la disait peut-être dans une
circonscription difficile dans l'essonne
tiens allons voir les salles c'est vrai
qu'on n'a pas forcément les résultats
tout de suite mais on peut trouver ça
peut-être sur le sur le site du figaro
n'a malheureusement pas les résultats
dans dans l'essonne mais alors si on n'a
pas les résultats sur le site du figaro
on va aller chercher si vous le voulez
bien sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur est ce qu on a les résultats
dans l'essonne dans la sixième
circonscription oui nous les avons alors
là c'est très intéressant regarder
jérôme guedj l'ancien
député socialiste un kiné est député
depuis cinq ans il était député sous
françois hollande eh bien regardez il
est en tête il a une jolie avance alors
c'est vraiment un match à 2 37 53% des
suffrages pour le candidat de
l'allemagne où paissent madame amélie de
montchanin qui est ministre de la
transition écologique c'est bien savoir
si bien ça c'est bien ça eh bien elle
est en est au deuxième tour ça c'est ce
qui lui donne de l'espoir pour rester à
son poste de ministre parce qu'on le
rappelle si elle venait à perdre elle
devrait quitter le gouvernement mais
elle n'est pas en très bonne posture ah
mais non celle là vous le voyez donc
dans cette sixième circonscription de
l'essonne d'autres questions je continue
avec mes petits ministre on peut
continuer avec les mille soleils et
n'hésitez pas à vous nous demandez vous
sur twitch sur lefigaro.fr sur youtube
sur j'ai oublié quoi sur facebook
évidemment et vous nous posez des
questions pour savoir quels sont les
résultats dans votre commune on n'a pas
cherché qui encore tiens marc fesneau
vous savez
ministre de l'agriculture il est dans la
première du loir-et-cher première
circonscription du loiret cher et donc
marc fesneau qu'at-il fait et il
qualifié pour le second tour oui il est
qualifié pour le second tour le ministre
ancien ministre des relations avec le
parlement un sou le dernier quinquennat
marc fesneau il est au second tour
devant reda belkadi de la nu baisse
voilà qui allie fier pour le second tour
également le rassemblement national
échoue à environ 800 voix tout pile 800
voix d'ailleurs mais donc marc fesneau
aura un second tour face à la nuit
baisse on suivra attentivement ses duels
entre les ministres et les candidats qui
veulent voir arriver jean luc mélenchon
au poste de premier ministre qu'il
espère évidemment on a autre chose
toujours pas alors je monte un petit peu
vous pouvez voir alors il ya d'autres
personnes qu'on a envie de voir par
exemple marine le pen et oui ça ça nous
intéresse parce qu'elle est candidate
marine le pen j'ai vu tout à l'heure qui
avait fait plutôt un bon score mais tout
n'était pas encore tout n'était pas
encore dépouillés elle est dans le pas
de calais marine le pen allons voir dans
le pas de calais ce qu'elle est ce
qu'elle fait
on regarde dans le pas de calais la 11e
circonscription oui regardez qualifié
pour le pour le second tour mais elle ne
semblait pas élu parce qu'elle n'a pas
il me semble le nombre d'inscrits
suffisant 1 c'est comme ça que ça marche
parce que s'il allait à 53,96 à moins
qu'ils aient une petite erreur comment
ça se passe que normalement 53 on est en
équipe alors directement voir aller
vérifier sur le
site du ministère intérieur il faut
effectivement avoir 25% des inscrits ça
je n'aurais pas les 25% des inscrits
marine le pen 11ème circonscription du
pas de calais non non elle est en elle
est en ballottage alors qu il voyait
pourrait bien expliquons parce que ça
c'est très intéressés un peu la
subtilité de ces législatives
vous pouvez avoir donc plus de 50% des
voix exprimées mais il faut également
avoir pour être donc élu dès le premier
tour 25% des inscrits voilà donc si
marine le pen est à 22 53 % donc elle se
retrouve au second tour avec un candidat
qui lui n'a pas atteint les 12 5 % des
inscrits normalement requis pour accéder
au second tour est ce que vous me suivez
mais je vous suis alors c'est compliqué
c'est alors oui c'est un peu paradoxal
mais ça on regarde surtout en fait le
résultat voilà donc l ael adam parr
exprimé draghi tous les gens qui ont
voté elle a obtenu 53
96% des votes mais n'a que 22 points 53
% des inscrits et pour gagner pour être
officiellement député il faut obtenir 25
% des inscrits c'est pour ça que marine
le pen même si elle atteint 53 96% des
votes exprimés n'est toujours pas
députés pour un d'un second mandat
consécutif
elle sera face à marine tondelier au
deuxième tour bon c'est bien parti pour
marine le pen mais mais il va falloir se
frotter deuxième sur la semaine
prochaine est ce qu'on a d'autres
questions est ce que je vous propose
d'autres personnalités alors on amorim
sur facebook bonjour maureen bienvenue
dit nous montauban à montaut bon c'est
un peu dans le sud de fou allez je vous
oblige pas faire l'accent de montauban
dans le tarn-et-garonne valérie rabault
intéressant et valérie rabault 20 qui
étaient là la patronne des députés ps
depuis quelques années à l'assemblée qui
est sous la bannière de la nouvelle
arrive en tête dans cette commune de
montauban devant catherine simona
d'ensemble et pierre poma du
rassemblement national les républicains
sont un peu décrochés avec claude
vigouroux mais on va voir ce qui se
passe sur l'ensemble de la
circonscription dans le tarn et garonne
elle est qualifiée pour le second tour
valérie rabault 33,33 % et voilà comme
ça c'est facile
15,15 1763 voix et donc elle sera au
second tour n'ont pas avec la candidate
de ensemble qui est arrivé deuxième à
montauban mais face à pierre poma on
aura donc un duel entre la nuque ps et
le rassemblement national pas de
majorité présidentielle dans cette 1re
circonscription du tarn et garonne voilà
pour maureen c'est ça exactement maureen
montréal alors juste en dessous mais
nous avons mario qui nous demande mario
résultat à je vais lui votre luigi
dites-moi bilieux by you i l des vues
elles et eux y avaient gelé 38 dans
l'isère billio t on ira voir à quoi ça
ressemble et où c'est exactement pascal
pruvost d'ensemble il est en tête devant
dominique guichard de la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale le
rassemblement national est 3e on va voir
ce qui se passe sur l'ensemble de la
circonscription
c'est la septième de l'isère arts n'a
pas les résultats malheureusement vous
savez ce qu'on va faire comme d'habitude
on va sur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur on va retrouver l'isère dans
le 38 évidemment et donc quelle
circonscription nous avons dit la 7e
c'est à dire ça et la 7è nous avons les
résultats nous avons donc un deuxième
tour entre tient donc à l air yannick
neuder qui est en tête devant un
candidat et rennes on a voté à droite un
visiblement dans cette circonscription
de l'isère la 7e dominique dicharry les
choux allez un peu plus de 1000 voix
pour la nuque baisse et pas de candidats
ensemble parce qu'elle prive au n'est
donc pas qualifié non plus avec neuf une
voix ça a été serré vous avez vu 24 23
20 19 ça donc j'ai l'impression de
revenir un présidentielle des quelques
années il y a cinq ans mais non non non
il n'y aura pas de quadrangulaires ici
puisque les candidats n'ont pas atteint
12 5% des inscrits il y aura donc un
deuxième tour simple yannick neuder dlr
face à alexandre moulin compte du rn
dans cette septième circonscription de
l'isère
alors sur facebook toujours on à renault
bonjour renault attendez on avait promis
quelque chose à voir sur bien sûr voir
alors attendez parce que je me suis
perdu dans toute cette histoire nous
étions qui a été le nom de la commune
déjà vous m'avez dit bilieux 1 c'est
bien que certains milieux on est déjà
allé dans les airs sur une petite
commune espoir que ce soit bucolique
saibil eu lieu alors milieu on est au
bord d'un lac du lac de paladru sachez
le regardez on des zooms un petit peu
pour voir oui on est amis on est dans le
nord de grenoble veille au nord de voir
on habille le salaire très calme milieu
l'un des mets ses mots dernier des
bâtiments un peu voilà voilà voilà là
vous là vous voyez j'ai j'ai vu votre
sourire mon char adrien voilà bilieux
scénario qui nous demandait ça
exactement rien on amuse et
archéologiques musées archéologiques du
lac de paladru voilà sachez le il ya des
choses à faire habitué des choses à
faire partout en france de toute façon
puis surtout un paysage magnifique a
observé dites moi on a notre commune oui
on a vieilli un avis pardon vienne
vienne a annonc é nor ça sur facebook
viennent tout de suite pas en autriche
j'aurais du mal à trouver sans s en s
viennent absolument jean claude lassalle
des républicains qui est donc en tête
dans sept dans cette commune devienne
devant quentin dogon delanoue ps et
caroline abadie d'ensemble c'est assez
serré même si les républicains ont une
petite avance le rassemblement national
n'est qu'à 12 23% on va voir on est dans
quelle circonscription toujours dans
l'isère c'est la 8e cette fois et donc
caroline abadie ou la regarder comme
c'est serré mon cher adrien 9113 voix
devant le rassemblement national 9000
cette voie et donc quand un dogon de la
nuit baisse ne se qualifie pas pour le
second tour pour seulement 12 voix ah
oui alors là je crois que c'est leur
tout petit les sharks ont intrigué les
30 voix de tout à l'heure et huawei 12
voix et alors vous avez vu parce que il
était
vraiment très proches également du
premier en finale - ont il est à moins
de aller à peine à peine plus de cent
voix et regardez jean claude lassalle
des républicains lui aussi dû 8213 voix
c'était une bataille acharnée dans cette
circonscription mais au second tour la
semaine prochaine vous ne pourrez mettre
que deux bulletins celui soit caroline
abadie soit celui de benoît august
faudra choisir et non quand un dogue on
n'est pas qualifiés ni jean claude
lassalle pour les républicains deuxième
tour ensemble contre le rassemblement
national dans la 8e circonscription de
l'isère allez on a de nouveau quelques
commentaires sur facebook c'est gertie
d'être avec nous
encore des franciliens il ya beaucoup de
français ce soir mais on les salue
endroit et que vous avez un problème
avec les franciliens j'ai eu quelques
communes ont voté non j'ai que j'ai cru
entendre au son de votre voix vous étiez
pas content allons-y les français bien
jocelyne à jocelyne avec ballon pour
dévaliser lines est ouverte et à nc vous
le dit bien vite vous m'avez vous être
que dans des chiffres et des lettres jeu
est faux je vous suivent à on a déjà eu
cette circonscription je crois tout à
l'heure nathalie da conceicao carvalho
en tête du rassemblement national à
ballancourt sur essonne mathieu hilaire
et 2e naïma siffert d'ensemble est 3e on
va voir très vite hop on regarde ce qui
se passe dans l'ensemble de la
circonscription malheureusement on n'a
pas les résultats mais pour jocelyne qui
nous rejoue on va retourner dans la 2e
circonscription de l'essonne pour lui
dire dans l'essonne dans cette
circonscription qui elle pourra choisir
la semaine prochaine alors résultats
partiels attention tout n'est pas joué
mais on a déjà une belle base mais mais
c'est très serré regardez nathalie da
conceicao carvalho est en tête pour
l'instant devant le candidat de l'ani
baisse mais naïma siffert 7840 voix elle
peut encore espérer se qualifier 1 parce
que il reste à les
quinze 15 % des électeurs inscrits à
dépouiller pour pour essayer deux eh
bien pourquoi pas pour cette candidate
d'ensemble même si c'est vrai que c'est
mal embarqué essayez d'atteindre le
second tour voilà ma charge au spleen
à sur youtube à
quelques personnes qui nous rejoignent
nous avons l fox renault sur mon père
fox qui nous devons ça s'écrit
plf au xx e j'aimerais beaucoup qu'elle
fox nous disent que ça veut dire si
belle fois que c'est toujours bon alors
on fait un deal pickford pelles fox vous
nous dites que veut dire votre votre
pseudo et moi je vous donne le résultat
ou sa rambervilliers rambervillers air à
m j'imagine
comme ça à regarder dans les vosges
alors dans les vosges dans cette commune
de rambervillers cette petite commune
c'est stéphane bierry dlr qui est en
tête devant et mimoun du rassemblement
national et anne sophie anne sophie
monash d'ensemble jules fait d'être de
la nuque baisse et 4e c'est assez serré
allons voir ce qui se passe sur
l'ensemble de la circonscription c'est
la première des vosges et donc stéphane
viry est en tête assez largement vous
avez vu 37,21 % pour le candidat des dlr
c'est pas pas pas fréquent en noir
d'avoir dlr en tête dans ce qu'on a vu
depuis le début de ce live devant et
mimoun ceux du rassemblement national
jules fêter ne se qualifie pas mais ça
joue à aller 700 800 voix à peu près on
peut descendre qui était qui était le
député est ce que c'était déjà stéphane
bierry oui c'est fn virent y regarder 53
12 % des voix à l'époque cet étang en
2017 il avait eu
face à lui une candidate en marche
helsana mla bien cette fois il aura une
candidate du rassemblement national
est-ce qu'on a autre chose est ce que
peut il faut qu'on nous a dit ce que oui
alors que nous dit que c'est un surnom
que ses amis lui donne donc ça nous oui
on peut être ses amis à l'appeler comme
ça amène il peut être qu'ils n'osent pas
nous dire non c'est un très grand merci
pas le bon exemple le cas des vosges
visiblement alors qu'est ce que nous
avons ici nous avons sur facebook romane
qui nous bonsoir romane
les résultats à cherbourg qui servit
amis circonscription de la manche bien
sûr cherbourg charlesbourg charlesbourg
tout court sherbrooke sherbrooke à ces
on-dit charleville - charles hamelin ans
avait des choses sherbrooke octeville
anna pic et est en tête 34
85% des voix à cherbourg sonia crimi
d'ensemble 29,30 eric fouace du
rassemblement national est en troisième
position alors il ya de la vence pour
ces deux candidats à charbon mais sur
l'ensemble de la circonscription ça
donne quoi et bien c'est pareil anna pic
est en tête alors de peu 1 31 61 contre
39 14 contre sony akrimi pas de
triangulaire eric fouace et éliminée et
donc il y aura un deuxième tour ça sert
et là dans cette circonscription de de
la manche la quatrième circonscription
de la manche celle de cherbourg qui
était la députée sortante où le député
cdh et sony akrimi qui étaient divers
vous voyez à quel avait battu un
candidat en marche eh bien cette fois
c'est bien elle qui représente le camp
de la majorité pour ensemble face à anne
applique
alors on va retourner sur facebook en
fait vous allez allons-y bien sûr
youtube facebook lefigaro.fr et which it
is a exactement my va donc sur facebook
qui me demandent vous enlève à à la
arles a bien sûr on retourne dans le
dans le sud dans les bouches du rhône à
arles à christophe caillaud delà du ps
il est en tête devant marianne à cailhau
d'ensemble emmanuel tâche de l'apa gurry
pour le rassemblement national après
c'est beaucoup plus bas pour reconquête
allons voir sur l'ensemble de la de la
circonscription à arles à cette
circonscription des bouches du rhône
bouches du rhône département
des fois les résultats exemple plus tard
que d'habitude mais on a les résultats
regarder sur les bouches du rhône nous
aurons un second tour entre le
rassemblement national des manuels tâche
de la pagerie face à christophe caillaud
de la nu ps n'a les 1500 voix d'écart
pour l'instant après ce premier tour ça
risque d'être d'être d'être serrée dans
cette dans cette circonscription mais
dans la 16ème circonscription des
bouches du rhône il ya beaucoup de
circonscriptions dans ce département
voilà vous savez tout je sais plus je me
souviens plus du prénom de maeva voilà
vous savez tout maeva
on repart sur youtube oui mais je veux
bien nous avons
un air d'été qui nous demandent des
résultats dans la troisième
circonscription du calvados très précis
oui vous pouvez nous donner le nom de la
commune on vous les connaissez de la
circonscription bien sûr alors calvados
on est déjà allé tout à l'heure pour
voir ce qu'ils avaient fait il avait
deux bandes qui est en tête on rappelle
troisième circonscription du calvados
martine wille mais du rassemblement
national c'est elle qui est en tête pour
l'instant mais de peu 1 vous avez vu 24
25% face à 22,42 pour jérémy patrier let
us qui lui est pour ensemble à la
coalition de de la majorité avec un
rappel le modem en marché horizon le
parti d'edouard philippe nathalie porte
des républicains elle est éliminée oui
ça s'est pas joué à grand-chose 8311
doit il ya à peine deux cents voix
d'écart et c'est pareil pour didier canu
delà de la nuit passe lui aussi l'avait
dépasser les 8000 24 candidats à plus de
21% mais mais mais pas de pas de
triangulaire need quoi de régulière
parce que on sait on l'a dit j'en fais
tomber mon stylo et bien s'il n'y a pas
assez d'électeurs on doit prendre en
compte le nombre d'inscrits regarder qui
était le député à l'époque et et bien
c'était sébastien leclerc des
républicains nous aurons donc un nouveau
député dans cette circonscription entre
martine wille mai et jérémy patrier
lathus
alors sûr je vous laisse ramasser votre
stylo alors attendez je me suis éloigné
du micro je ramasse mon stylo c'est bon
je suis là à nouveau dit moi on a
quelqu'un d'autre prendra françoise
françois agit sur facebook nous demande
les résultats dans la 8e circonscription
de l'isère isère on est beaucoup à aller
dans l'isère il ya une une revendication
forte des isérois ce soir caroline have
a dit oui il faut qu'on est déjà allé
tout à l'heure caroline abadie ensemble
face à benoit oui c'est cette
circonscription extrêmement serré vous
souvenez la plus serrée cette voix
d'écart oui c'est ça dans douze voix
d'écart c'est ce qu'il a manqué à
quentin dogon pour se qualifier on avait
on n'a pas vu plus serrée 1 pour
l'instant et je vous le montre dites moi
les gens ne voient pas être tac on voit
tout donc qualifier au deuxième tour
caroline abadie benoît august et quentin
dogon qui malheureusement pour lui est
éliminée avec seulement douze petites
voix c'est ce qui lui a manqué dans
cette 8ème circonscription de l'isère
alors on à natacha qui nous demandent la
corrèze alors là oui plusieurs
circonscriptions évidemment
je vais faire un petit tour en corrèze
alors il ya deux circonscriptions corps
et donc c'est bien simple on va faire
fuir nourrir les alors sandrine deux
veaux de la nuque baisse elle est en
tête ça c'est donc dans la première
circonscription on aura un duel si j'ose
dire à l'ancien sandrine de vos fins à
francis dubois la gauche contre la
droite la nuque baisse face aux
républicains christophe geraghty lui il
est éliminé ça s'est pas joué à grand
chose non plus il a 19 32% des voix re
année on est à 700 voix d'écart à peu
près voilà pour cette première
circonscription de la corrèze duel entre
la nuque baisse et les républicains la
deuxième c'est ça que vous voulez savoir
en corrèze pour faire plaisir à rappeler
mois le prénom de la tache sur notre
internaute natacha natacha natacha tâche
à regarder
dans alors là j'ai j'ai un
gecko rays en fait j'ai la ville mais en
fait je veux directement la 2e
circonscription ici regardez voilà on y
est frédéric meunier des républicains là
aussi duel à l'ancienne face à la nuque
est clos et herzhaft est donc un second
tour entre ces deux candidats frédéric
et chloé à frédérick e mailing que c'est
une dame très directe meunier et chloé
herzhaft nicolas bruce d'ensemble échoue
il n'est que troisième mais il ne se
qualifie pas pour le second tour voilà
vous savez tout natacha sur ce qui se
passe en en corrèze deux duels entre les
républicains à la nuque baisses
allant faire un tour sur youtube
on va prendre le commentaire de vivies
mon soir bienvenue vie j vianne vivien
vivian à ben on peut lui demander pour
après tout c'est bien le principe du
pseudo c'est pour pas dire son prénom 10
de moins dix vies vivi nous demande les
résultats dans la 8e circonscription des
hauts-de-seine à ossen alors on a déjà
eu les os et les tout à l'heure je crois
qu'on est allé voir gabriel attal qui
était en excellente posture
hauts-de-seine malheureusement
maintenant des résultats sur le site du
figaro on va essayer d'aller chercher
sur le site du ministère de l'intérieur
allons-y 8e circonscription alors je
suis dans quelque temps la cheville dans
l'essonne les hauts de seine c'est juste
après le 92 allons-y 8e circonscription
nous avons les résultats et donc prisca
thévenot ah oui c'est cette cette porte
parole de la république en marche
devenus ensemble qui avait été investi
et qui est donc en tête assez largement
vous avez vu alors elle n'est pas
qualifiée directement et pas vainqueur
directement mais bon c'est bien parti
pour l ani laroque comme moi de la nuque
baisse elle est deuxième avec 24,25 vous
avez le score tout à droite pour voir
l'écart 40,12 contre 24,25 les alertes
sont éliminés ici dans cette huitième
circonscription des hauts-de-seine
cécile riche et ne parvient pas à
accéder au deuxième tour et donc prisca
thévenot elle est bien partie mais mais
un deuxième tour c'est la semaine
prochaine et toujours singulières non ah
oui alors celui qui l'internaute qui
nous trouvent une triangulaire chapeau
bas ouais très difficile on n'a pas vu
triangulaire on verra si on a beaucoup
sur l'ensemble du territoire ce serait
miraculeux mais les miracles existent
peut-être mon cher à dre allons-y une
autre commune sur youtube oui j'estime
de a
beaucoup de circonscriptions c'est là il
il veut la cinquième de bourgoin à de
bourgogne ça va pas marcher parce que
alors non on est sisi de côte-d'or pas à
être autant
je me disais alors côte d'or on est
bourré avec la sixième c'est bien ça hop
je cherche dans les entrailles côte-d'or
6 il faut taper mélanger que cinq
circonscriptions en côte-d'or
5e par la cinquième allons-y côte-d'or
5e circonscription didier paris est en
tête pour ensemble c'est le parti de la
majorité évidemment et il sera au second
tour face à rené y aurait sept candidats
du rassemblement national à les 1200
voix d'écart au premier tour dans cette
cinquième circonscription de la côte
d'or
isabelle de almeida et bien elle est
éliminée la candidate de la nuit ps lui
a manqué près de 2000 voix et donc nous
aurons un second tour entre l'ensemble
et le rassemblement national tiens donc
ça nous fait penser à l'élection
présidentielle il ya beaucoup de
ensemble et rennes dans ces premiers
tours nous verrons nous suivrons combien
rassemblement national arrive à avoir
deux députés sur l'ensemble du pays on a
quelqu'un d'autre pour l'instant non eh
bien vous savez ce qu'on fait on repart
et on cherche nos personnalités
tireur jean michel blanquer
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale voulait savoir ce qui lui est
arrivé emploi on va bien ou en mal il
était dans le loiret jean michel
blanquer dans la 4e circonscription du
loiret il est éliminé jean michel
blanquer à regarder cela thomas ménager
ses candidats du rassemblement national
il arrive en tête 31 points 45% des voix
devant bruno noter une belle avance un
attention dans cette circonscription du
loiret brune au teint de la deûle à nu
ps et jean michel blanc tiers donc
figure de proue de la macro ni depuis
plusieurs années ministre pendant cinq
ans sans arrêt non-stop du ministère de
l'éducation nationale ministre de
l'éducation nationale non reconduit dans
ce gouvernement et donc il est éliminé
il lui a manqué 189 voix on imagine que
dans cette circonscription il ya
peut-être eu comme souvent lorsqu'il ya
une tonne une personnalité une
croissance en termes de vote on peut
aller voir d'ailleurs est ce que on a un
peu plus voter qu'ailleurs ouais c'est
similaire 52,21 % d'abstentionnistes
dans cette circonscription est ce qu'on
a quelqu'un d'autre ou est ce que je
vous propose une autre circonscription
pourquoi ces nouveaux savoirs à
marseille vous souvenez jean luc
mélenchon il a laissé la place à manuel
bompard pour luc mélenchon qui était
ministre allons voir marseille 5e
circonscription
4e circonscription est ce qu'on a déjà
les résultats c'est peut-être pas si
facile
est ce qu'on l'a est-ce qu'on laisse
qu'on l'a on va peut-être aller voir sur
le ministère de l'intérieur vous savez
qu on a aussi cette solution ce soir on
cherche partout dans le xiii 4e
circonscription je descends je descends
je descends je remonte à hénon voyez
regarder les cette première
circonscription ce sont les
circonscriptions de marseille évidemment
dans les grandes villes les pouilles
mans un peu plus longue jean n'a pas
malheureusement assez de données pour
vous donner les résultats nous verrons
cela est-ce qu'on a une autre question
est pour l'instant allons-y on va
chercher ailleurs sur des ministres
pourquoi pas il est 23h30 de aller en
ensemble encore quelques instants si
vous avez des questions sur votre
circonscription sur votre commune vous
n'hésitez pas vous nous faites un petit
message qu'on essaie de vous donner des
réponses pour savoir qui est au second
tour chez vous on a vu ce qui avait fait
lisabeth bornes on a vu ce qui avait
fait gérald darmanin ce qui a fait
ameline manche alors en difficulté à
mairie de montchalin vous souvenez face
à jérôme guedj dans la sixième
circonscription de l'essonne on l'a vu
ce qu'a fait brigitte bourguignon je
crois qu'on n'a pas vu ce qui a fait
oublier du soft c'est le ministre du
travail olivier dussopt petit lait dans
l'ardèche il est dans la 2e
circonscription de l'ardèche et on va
essayer de voir où il en est l'ailé en
tête olivet du socle ministre 30 0 4%
des suffrages devant christophe gulu
zèle c'est le candidat de l'ani baisse
cyril grangier troisième du
rassemblement national bon c'est pas
fait il y aura un deuxième tour mais
c'est bien partis quand même pour
olivier dussopt qui est une petite
avance et en effet mais en tout cas il
en avance il est au deuxième tour à ce
qu'il ya quelque chose ailleurs c'est un
si vous voulez je vous propose qu'on
aille voir ce qu'a fait peut-être yale
brawn pie v tiens
elle est ministre des outre-mer aller
dans les yvelines 5e circonscription des
yvelines cette nouvelle ministre que
vous allez apprendre à découvrir
évidemment alors on n'a pas les
résultats malheureusement sur
lefigaro.fr on retourne sur le ministère
de l'intérieur le site du ministère de
l'intérieur on descend pour trouver les
yvelines ah ben c'est un tout petit peu
plus bas alors est-ce que je les hais
les yvelines 78 c'est ça j'y suis 78 on
a dit 5e circonscription
ayez le brunch iv est en tête assez
largement
36,59 % des suffrages devant sophie
thévenet c'est la candidate de la deûle
à nu ps voilà ce qu'on peut dire pour
l'instant est ce qu'on a d'autres
questions d'autres commentaires parce
qu'on les prend évidemment et on répond
à toutes vos questions il nous reste
quelques instants quelques minutes
ensemble donc n'hésitez pas bien sûr
alors rappeler aux gens qu'ils nous
rejoignent peut-être qu'on fait ici et
comment on fait alors c'est simple non
un moteur de recherche ou au figaro qui
nous permet de voir donc les résultats
du premier tour des législatives tout
simplement et vous il vous suffit de
nous donner donc soit le nom votre
commune soit le nom de la
circonscription où les deux et
un peu tous rentrés dans ce moteur de
recherche pour trouver assez facilement
les résultats donc que ce soit sur
facebook youtube le figaro.fr ou twitch
n'hésitez pas voilà vous me dîtes si on
ad'autres d'autres d'autres questions
d'autres résultats sinon on peut essayer
par exemple de trouver ce qui a fait
justine bénin c'est la ministre de la
mer elle est dans la deuxième
circonscription de la guadeloupe alors
on peut faire les dom-tom aux siens
c'est vrai qu'on n'est pas trop aller ce
soir 2e circonscription à ce qu'on a des
résultats oui justine bénin elle est en
tête
c'est pas évident n'a pas encore gagné
mais regardez l ai dit 'si 31 31%
6468 voix devant christian baptiste
divers-gauche
26,70 % des des suffrages voilà ce qu'on
pouvait dire alors il ya d'autres
ministres évidemment qu'ils sont en
liste on pensa à clément bonne dans le
7ème circonscription de paris mais c'est
pour ça que je vous montre pas parce que
malheureusement on n'a pas encore tous
les résultats dans ces grandes villes
stanislas guérini aussi dans la
troisième circonscription de paris
olivier à grégoire la porte parole du
gouvernement dans la 12e circonscription
de paris voilà des grandes villes donc
pour l'instant c'est un peu un peu
difficile on a fait le tour est ce qu'on
a encore des questions ou est ce que bon
voilà les gens ont eu ce qu'ils
voulaient ce qu'ils ont tous demandé
parce que je voudrais pas qu'on frustre
certains internautes un réel surtout pas
frustré tartine à à tartines et bien on
this fleur d'oranger un tartinerie c'est
joli
vous avez forme je commence à avoir un
petit peu fin ça fait un moment qu'on
est là après deux heures ensemble pour
essayer de vous donner tous les
résultats tout ce qui vous intéresse
starting donc c'est sur facebook oui et
tu nous demandes est large et 1 la
deuxième circonscription du tarn à le
tarn allons-y le tarn 2e circonscription
nous y sommes et bien c'est une
candidate de la nuque est qui est en
tête c'est karen et roady et c'est assez
serré face à marie christine et verdier
jouclas oui c'est une députée déjà en
place un qui joue sa réélection bien
c'est serré dans cette dans cette
circonscription du tarn
17400 voix pour karen héros 10,16 1487
ya moins de 1000 voix d'écart et
regardez mon cher adrien qu'est ce qu'on
voit là une triangulaire exactement et
oui julien bakou la première
triangulaire qualifié pour le second
tour c'est la première triangulaire que
nous voyons en tout cas julien bakou 23
points 68 % des suffrages nous aurons
donc trois candidats
dans cette circonscription du tarn alors
ce que je vous propose c'est qu'on aille
voir plus précisément les résultats
s'ils voulaient sur le ministère de
l'intérieur parce que c'est intéressant
c'est intéressant d'expliquer que les
triangulaires cette année sont plus
difficile que d'habitude
parce que vous le voyez on est dans la
2e circonscription il me semble oui
c'est bien ça eh bien il faut atteindre
12 5 % des inscrits et julien bajus tout
réussi 12
54% ça va être très intéressant tient
parce qu'il va pas y avoir beaucoup de
triangulaires alors celle là je la note
parce que la semaine prochaine on est
encore ensemble et on ira voir ce qu'il
s'est passé ici et qui obtiendra le
graal de devenir député est ce que
marie-christine verdier jouclas la
candidate d'ensemble conservera son
poste oui ou non voilà il y à une
triangulaire on finit là dessus où on a
du monde encore aller on a on a un
dernier camp a alors allons-y c'est sur
le site en plus donc reid le salut nazi
c'est à ces bébés à hasebe bienvenue
demande les résultats à marcq en baroeul
à marcq en baroeul ouais je vois alors
crois que ça s'est fait comme ça marque
exactement et bien c'est non il n'y a
pas de ses liens qu il ya un seuil avait
bien ça il ya bien c'est bien parce
que oui c'est ça je suis allé trop loin
marcq en baroeul exactement c'est
évidemment dans le nord et vous voyez
qu'ici violette spillebout est arrivé en
tête c'est la candidate ensemble devant
le candidat des républicains en devant
la candidate de la nuque baisse c'est un
peu plus compliqué pour christine landru
du rassemblement national ce qui nous
intéresse c'est de savoir ce qui se
passe dans la circonscription dans la
circonscription c'est la neuvième du
nord on y va et donc violette spillebout
est qualifié pour le second tour 31 92 %
des voix et non elle n'est pas face au
candidat des républicains elle efface à
odile vidal sagnier c'est elle qui
représente la nuque baisse 22 27 22% des
voix y aura match il y aura match dans
cette dans cette circonscription suivra
ça même si la candidate d'ensemble est
bien partis quand même dans le nord
circonscriptions de la ville de marcq en
baroeul voilà et on n'a pas de compte eh
bien je crois qu'on va arrêter là parce
que je pense qu'on a répondu à tous les
internautes alors évidemment vous pouvez
continuer à faire tout ça tout ce qu'on
vous a montré évidemment ce soir vous
pouvez le faire chez vous vous
recherchez un résultat vous tapez le nom
de votre commune vous tapez le nom de
votre circonscription le chiffre le
département et le chiffre derrière vous
trouvez tout vous avez tous les
résultats merci beaucoup adrien merci
thibault je pense qu'on sera là la
semaine prochaine parce que on suivra
attentivement ce qui se passe dehors
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas pu donner le
nom les résultats de certaines villes
par exemple à paris parce que les
résultats arrivent un peu plus tard mais
on suivra ça très attentivement dans
l'est dans les jours qui viennent dans
les heures qui viennent même merci
beaucoup merci de nous avoir suivis vous
pouvez continuer à suivre où ils 23h39
sur le flux principal la grande soirée
de delà de la présidentielle avec avec
brune d'audrey avec vincent roux merci
de nous avoir accompagnés merci de nous
avoir poser toutes ces questions on se
retrouve très bientôt excellente soirée
sur figaro lundi